the whole of nutrition advice had been
so muddled and confused it's not about
you know that one thing that you do or
you don't do it's about the holistic
view what can you get on your plate if
three quarters of it's filled with a
giant steak there's not much room for
your plants
food is medicine we are now at the
threshold do prescribed foods to
sidestep disease predict diagnostic
outcomes and enhance well-being on a
highly individuated basis and at the
pointy tip of this revolution is today's
guest Dr Tim Spector Professor Tim
Spector Professor Spector medical
Professor Tim Spector many consider you
to be the leading expert on gut health
and diet Tim is a globally renowned
epidemiologist geneticist and author
microbes are these microscopic organisms
this builds this community in your gut
only recently we've discovered are like
many pharmacies awarded the distinction
of order of the British Empire Tim is
also the best-selling author of several
books including the diet myth and his
latest food for life is an in-depth
scientific breakdown on what to eat when
and why to improve our own personal
nutrition in this episode we expand upon
my many past conversations about the
microbiome we talk about the importance
of plant diversity in one's diet we talk
about the Environmental implications of
food systems and consumer food choices
the future of food microbiome science
and plenty more before we dive in this
episode is brought to you today by Roca
now I get asked fairly consistently
about the very stylish spectacles you
always see me wearing on the show well
the answer is Roca I love them
everything Roca makes is designed for
high performance all their glasses and
sunglasses are super light with premium
Optics these are the Hamilton frames but
Roca has tons of great Styles none of
which will ever slip off your face no
matter how much you sweat I'll be
sharing a bit more about Roka later but
right now let's get into it with Dr Tim
Spector this one is appointment
listening enjoy
well Tim it's a delight to have you here
today thank you for coming uh as I
mentioned to you a few minutes ago I've
had the privilege and the pleasure of
Hosting many conversations about the
microbiome about gut health over the
years including the good Dr B will
bolsowitz friend of the podcast he's
sitting right over there right now who
accompanied you but today is a
particular honor because as Dr B
insisted I made clear
you truly are the world's leading
Authority in this field at The Cutting
Edge of all this fascinating emerging
science uh that's creating a new way of
learning about how our bodies work how
they operate
um in the world and it's very exciting
so not only are you somebody who's
innovating new research uh you
are also pioneering this this
fascinating field that I want to learn
more about that we're calling citizen
science which we're going to get into
but I think the best place to begin is
just to understand what got you
interested in this field kind of the
origin story behind this and kind of
defining our terms uh with respect to
you know what we're talking about when
we're talking about gut health in the
microbiome
okay well it's great pleasure to be here
big fan of the podcast
um so very excited and my Journey's been
a bit of a long one so I we got time
plenty of time okay so
um because I'm old so that makes makes
months career longer
um I started Life as a a doctor went to
medical school
and
got interested in epidemiology which is
a study of populations
but there was no real jobs in that so I
trained as a rheumatologist studying
bones and joints
and
made my way training in that in in
London in in medical schools
and
on the way I did a masters in
epidemiology that was still interested
in that side of why diseases happen in
populations this sort of detective in me
that wanted to find out why things
happen
and I when I did my
um three years research and my thesis in
in that whole area and
it was early really really aft in about
30 years ago that I
um
I change tack from purely Rheumatology
and I started What's called the the
twins UK project which was setting up uh
these twin volunteer
system across the UK which now is 15 000
twins in it and has been running out for
30 years so that was the largest of its
kind in the world where we were
intensively looking at these twins as
they were getting older and looking at a
whole range of disease and obviously
started
with bones and joints
which are the time no one knew
you know much about and the whole idea
of the twin study was this nature of
inertia debate and it was really a
really cool time to be doing that
because
many of the diseases we thought were
purely due to Aging for example ended up
having a big genetic component
and
many things that we thought were genetic
ended up not being particularly jacked
so we found them back pain was three
times more genetic than breast cancer
interesting and also to interject here
uh you know the the state of science
with respect to what we understood about
genetics in 1992 is very different than
it is today yeah it's hard to believe
how much our opinions have changed
and how you know the scientists and
doctors at the time have had these fixed
views about everything was degenerative
it was just everything was wear and tear
and your body just wore out
and that was a common thing for anything
to do with aging and
the idea there were these big
differences between people really wasn't
really considered so it it was really
quite exciting to be able to
write these pivotal papers to disprove a
lot of you know clinical nonsense that
had been talked about and and why some
disease were given more priority than
others because they're more exciting
they're sexy diseases others were sort
of dull aging disorders so that was the
time we were living and it was also
just as the sort of genetic Revolution
was starting so we were starting at Gene
markers Etc but
um it took the first 10 years was really
convincing people that there was a
genetic component to common diseases at
up to that point really only been the
rare ones that people had focused on or
the sort of exciting ones so that was
a cool time and I
came out of my little field of you know
osteoporosis and arthritis and back pain
into all the other common chronic
disease of aging and that led us to
publish all kinds of fascinating work
and made me realize that I if you had a
model that worked you might as well
study all the interesting stuff you can
not be stuck in a in a specialty like
most of my colleagues remain so from
what I understand I mean obviously when
you're studying twins it's fascinating
to see a difference in outcomes between
two different people that share the same
genetic makeup and then trying to figure
out like why those what's driving those
that differential right
what aspect of their nurturing or their
environment is you know compelling one
to you know become ill and the other one
to remain healthy but was there some
sort of epiphany along the way that
triggered this Fascination that led you
into the microbiome or you know how did
that kind of evolve out of you know
studying these pairs over so many years
well I think I eventually got out of my
system that everything was genetic so um
I was telling everyone everything's
genetic it turns out that 50 is the out
of everything you name any disease 50
roughly is genetic and
that got a bit dull because I
and it's not a very satisfying no answer
it wasn't and it was useful because we
you know then went on to find genes but
as it turned out they weren't that
useful either other than maybe for
long-term drug targets and things but
for me I started looking more closely at
why identical twins who were basic
genetic clones and lived the first 18
years of their life completely together
ended up often dying of different
diseases so the aging process was
different there was no real genetic base
of longevity it was very small
one would die of cancer the other one
wouldn't one would get autoimmune
disease the other one wouldn't want me
depressed one wouldn't so I'm starting
to intrigued why we were seeing this
when you know all the previous stuff was
showing it was quite it seemed to be
genetic and yet the identical twins
which this perfect model of these it's
like you know all of us have this shadow
person that can be doing
in it living in a different environment
to us uh what happens to them it's like
you all own little control study and so
I was fascinated by this and I was then
determined to try and look and see what
were those factors was it gene mutations
that were different between them turned
out that wasn't the case I looked at
something called epigenetics which is
where you can switch genes on and off
with chemical signals did that for a few
years only small differences that
couldn't really explain these big
effects and it was then it was about
um
yeah 2000 about just over you know 11
years ago that I came across the
microbiome and said let's test this in
twins
and
that was really Epiphany because I found
that
identical twins had very different
microbes
and it was the first time I'd in you
know 20 odd years of studying them I'd
found something really different in
identical twins and suddenly I said wow
that's that's kind of
that is really cool because why should
they be different and yet if they are
different
that could explain
why we we all get different diseases
slightly what we thought was randomly
because of this whole new organ in our
bodies that is behaving very differently
in all of us and essentially producing
lots of different chemicals so I think
it was an aha moment both for realizing
you know this what we thought was this
randomness of disease
but importantly also changed
um my perception about how food works as
well and why that
why in a way the whole of nutrition
advice
had been so muddled and and confused and
seemingly with poor science
because we'd assumed everyone behaves
the same once that food goes into you
you know it's going to behave the same
way in everybody and suddenly knowing
that even identical twins they only
share maybe a quarter of their microbes
means that in response to the same food
they're all going to respond very
differently so that was the theoretical
moment when I said aha this could be
really interesting I'm going to spend
you know the next at least decade
working on this rather than all these
other areas which I could work on to try
and get to the bottom of it because I
think it could be much bigger than just
looking at a few microbes right so it is
quite a watershed moment or a paradigm
shift to realize or or to kind of
reflect upon this conventional
perspective which is
our genetic makeup is what
differentiates us and it becomes this
predictor of a variety of things but in
reality the genetic differences like
we're much more genetically similar than
we are different right and that's a very
you know set number of variables it's
still incredibly complex but it feels
very simplistic in comparison to the
diversity of the microbiome and
understanding that maybe a better way to
look at it is through the differences in
in you know these trillions of microbes
that are dramatically different from one
individual to the next irrespective of
similarities in their genetic makeup
like and using that as a lens and then
trying to to sort of wend that or tie
that to certain outcomes as a predictor
seems like an impossible not to untie
because of the infinite number of
variables involved
yeah it's it's sort of mind-boggling the
complexity of it but
I think
it's a it's becoming clear that
yes there are lots of different strains
and microbes and you know trillions of
them
but the thing that do does bind them in
common is they are essentially mini
pharmacies
they are taking the food as their sort
of consumables and pumping out all kinds
of chemicals that are unique to us and
our and our system and in completely in
different amounts and so there is a
certain amount of redundancy in these
microbes but
the difference and I think that the key
difference is not so much the micro but
they're the products they make the
chemicals and that's that's the
essential uh for me the big difference
is understanding food and nutrition
not as macronutrients or these rather
old-fashioned ways of looking at it but
in in in in chemicals that we are
converting one set of chemicals as food
by our microbes into these other
chemicals which have massive effects on
our immune system our brains and our
bodies and our health and
I think
as complex as the microbiome is it can
be simplified by understanding those
those chemicals and this whole science
of
metabolomics which is a study of
studying these metabolites so I don't
think it's an impossible
scenario at all and
luckily because of the genetic
Revolution
we have the tools now to measure our
microbiome incredibly accurately and
actually uncover you know 75 80 percent
of the of the microbes that are in there
which is pretty you know we wouldn't
believe that yeah yeah that's
unbelievable ten years ago and the cost
has come down from five thousand dollars
a sample you know to less than a hundred
dollars in in you know in 10 years so
it's it's been an incredible journey and
you know we're just
really scraping the surface of what we
know about these things but they have
huge potential
um in all kinds of areas not just in
nutrition but in sure Pharmacy and
fighting disease and and everything else
because of this all these incredible
chemicals they're producing all the time
that we co-evolved with
so before we even go any further it
would probably be good to just Define
what you mean when you say the
microbiome like what are we talking
about specifically in general terms the
microbiome is the term we use for the
community of microbes microorganisms
that live in our bodies and we generally
refer to the 99 that live in our lower
intestine are colon and the microbiome
really refers to the genes of those
microbes should technically be called
the microbiota and where you just use
them as microbiome because I'm not fussy
about words and everyone now understands
that so these there are
some dispute about how many there are
but they're probably they're certainly
trillions maybe a hundred trillion or so
roughly the same numbers of cells in our
body most of them are the ones we know
about are bacteria but they're also
these other related species called
Archaea and there are fungi and yeasts
and there are viruses five times as many
viruses as bacteria that feed off them
called phages which also have a role in
health and there are even parasites that
virtually all of us have to some extent
in our guts and some of which turn out
to be beneficial as well so it's this
whole Community a bit like an ecosystem
that is living within us and it best
considers a virtual organ
stick them all together they weigh about
two kilograms same as your brain and
they basically as I said these mini
pharmacies pumping out chemicals which
send signals all over a body but
particularly
to all the immune cells
the majority of which our immune cells
are actually lining our gut
and so they interact with those immune
cells on a constant basis
signaling whether to
be aggressive or be passive and
modifying them tuning them up and down
that helps fight aging helps fight
cancer
sorts out allergies
etc etc in fact fights infections
and they also produce lots of chemicals
that might go to our brain
um responsible for serotonins and many
other Pathways in the brain as well so
it affects our mood and obviously our
metabolism and how we digest food
amongst others right like so many things
right things but this idea that that our
immune system really resides in our gut
is kind of a shocking Revelation like I
always understood that our immune system
originates in our bone marrow and you
know this is where we're producing uh
yeah this is what yeah this is and and
and and and why is it that we didn't
begin to really even put these pieces
together in a methodical way until I
don't know the early 2000s like it seems
like you kind of got into this around
2011 right like this is all extremely
recent because prior to that
conventional wisdom was sort of like you
know parrot we got to get rid of
parasites and all this stuff this is
these These are plaguing the human and
body and at some point somebody figured
out like actually we're living
symbiotically with all of this and this
is crucial to every facet of health and
we're still it feels like in the very
early beginning stages of trying to
understand the true and vast
implications of this incredibly complex
system I think it was medical hubris
that says that you know our powerful
drugs can get rid of this stuff we're
fighting the West the well we know that
microbes have killed lots of people in
history infectious diseases you know
were vitally important we survived them
therefore you know we can beat them and
antibiotics sterilizing creams
um you know keeping people away from
dirt this is the way we're going to
conquer our sort of our fears and I
think it was a blind spot to realize
that the gut health really was important
and for so long just regarded that the
intestine is a tube to get rid of toxins
right and that sits nutrients some
people still believe that right but you
know particularly the toxin bit but the
um
not realizing it had such major
implications as a vital organ for us and
I think it was
you know a few people guessed at it and
even the you know you go back to the
days of 100 years ago mitchinkoff and uh
Pastor talking about yogurt they thought
it worked because it deputified the body
you know got rid of those toxins they
couldn't still imagine that it was
feeding
other other microbes inside there so I
think we just had a blind spot to it
some people believe the Indian ancient
Indian art you know understood the
what the sort of core of the gut to
health and so ancient Chinese and
ancient Indian did know but of course
they couldn't see these microorganisms
uh couldn't grow them
and uh this has been part of the problem
you know we right Medical Science just
couldn't see them until genetics came
along and so over the course of the 30
years under which the twins UK research
has been ongoing there's been like a
thousand research papers that have come
out of this what are some of the the
revelations that um have emanated out of
looking at twins through this lens oh
it's hard to pick highlights I think
because there were some Revelations at
the time they seemed might seem rather
dull now like I was saying you know back
pain is highly genetic uh might not
surprise people now to say you know but
um
um other ones were one of the first to
look at
that distribution was highly genetic so
whether when you put on weight with you
accumulate it in your belly or your or
your your bum uh really strongly genetic
and you can see that in families it's
sort of obvious
um we showed for the first time that
cataract wasn't just that was something
you inherited as well
um we looked at
um
early risk factors for melanoma found
that
um because everyone talks about melanoma
they're always talking about sunshine
which is a really overrated risk factor
for melanoma it's actually highly
heritable about whether you have these
lots of moles you have light skin and
lots of moles much stronger uh genetics
than anything else and so you can divide
people into those groups and twin
studies helped us with that and we did
sort of fun stuff we found sense of
humor wasn't particularly genetic
um political views were so your right
wing views or
um your left-wing views have a quite a
strong heritable basis interesting as
does belief in God
have a heritable basis so there's nearly
anything that you can quantify
you can
study in this way if it's if you can
quantify it reliably and get the similar
answer so it it allowed us to look at
um
sexuality as well and we're the first to
look at
the genetics of female sexuality and so
you can study any personality or trait
um in that way as well as
things like the microbiome
um epigenetics which you know again has
some genetic influences and even things
like vitamins so people always talking
about oh my vitamin D level is low well
we were the first to show how that was
strongly heritable
and that there are certain genes so 50
of the differences between say are
vitamin D levels are going to be due to
differences in our genes so what's
normal for you
isn't going to be normal for me and how
does epigenetics play into that from my
understanding epigenetics basically
um means uh the potential for genetic
expression and also this idea that
um
that were were kind of storing genetic
information passed on from our ancestors
that is perhaps latent but given the
right set of circumstances could be
expressed like how you know that that
seems like a Sticky Wicket and very
complicated to kind of understand and
there's a there's a certain aspect of it
that's that's sort of mystical in terms
of like
um the inheritance of of like ancestral
trauma and things like that like how
does that play into how you think about
this and and and and study populations
well I wrote a book about this called
identically different which nobody read
but I thought it was a great book but uh
you know as often the way and went into
a bit of this a bit theorizing about it
and it's it's been called Soft
inheritance so it's an inheritance we
think think it's an evolutionary
adaptation that allows in times of
stress or famine or some emotional
stress to just
um
switch the genes on or off in a way that
takes you on a different path
and to some extent and
the general belief is that it takes so
long to change your genes normally that
you know your whole family would have
been wiped out by that time you'd made
that switch but if this allows you to
add a there's a temperature change so
allows you to switch so you gain more
weight or just the fact that your family
might all be switching their genes so
that they end up more different they're
not all going to be wiped out by the
same
environmental stress or infective agent
makes some sort of sense so but it just
lasts for a couple of generations and
then Fizzles out so
it when I was looking at it I did
interview lots of identical twins who
went through stress for example
and
it was quite remarkable that say you
know a very major family breakup or
someone that teenage twins one for
example would responded by overeating
and got very obese and the other one had
an eating disorder and with anorexia so
they were acting in response to a stress
but very differently probably because
the
in theory you know the the genes were
were switched and doing something but
there was something in our
there's something in our Evolution that
allows us to have these switches and
make you depressed or happy in these
things so I think in response to stress
it does make some sense
um and there are lots of stories about
um after the war Dutch hunger famines
um whole populations having these
stresses which for several Generations
had effect on their mental health or
others due to these changing genes so
it's a lovely it's a nice Theory but
it's been really hard to prove it in
humans
mice it sort of works quite well is
often the case
um and you can change Mouse hair color
for example just by giving them
different vitamins and things switching
them epigenetically or giving them
alcohol or whatever
can't do that in humans so it's got to
be so frustrating to see you know
amazing kind of dramatic results in my
studies and not be able to replicate
that in humans I mean that seems to be
kind of like the robber Curry theme
across all areas of science millions of
scientists uh have have been frustrated
so that's why I didn't get that Nobel
Prize you know that so humans just don't
behave like mice it's very annoying
right and the my studies are what you
know generate a lot of hyperbolic
headlines in terms of breakthroughs it
creates a lot of consumer confusion and
they still do and and it's similar in
the microbiome it's not not very it's
not different and there were you know
some misleading studies in the early
days of the microbiome that just
um you know exaggerated the potential
effects in in humans so they were you
know I think they were accurate but they
just
from Mouse studies you can't really get
an idea of the scale or the effect in
humans you don't know it's trivial or
it's really large and I think that's the
other sort of problem about
extrapolating and uh you know we're not
we're not rodents and um we have very
different lives and we eat different
things and uh
so yeah more and more
you know we realized a lot of these male
studies were flawed and of course you
can do unlimited number of mouse studies
you know you've got labs well-funded
labs they can afford to slaughter
thousands of mice and they don't
necessarily report every experiment they
do right and that's the other problem
which human trials they take so long to
do you you know whether it failed or not
you're going to write it up because it's
uh it's important yeah
today by Roca glasses are not something
you normally think about as a piece of
performance gear which when you think
about it is kind of insane because you
can't perform at your best if you can't
see well the Geniuses at Roka basically
rebuild eyewear from the ground up no
matter how active you are or how much
you sweat these things never slip or
fall off your face they're super durable
they look awesome and they've got tons
of super classy modern styles to choose
from I've been rocking rokas for about
four years at this point I love them I'm
a big fan of the Hamilton style in gloss
black that's this Frame right here as
well as clear or I guess they call them
vintage on the website and if you want
to try them out for yourself you can do
that right now and unlock 20 off your
order with the code Rich Roll at
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
so you're starting to develop this this
you know growing sense that the
microbiome is is is playing a much more
crucial crucial role than than
previously imagined and and you know
this sort of leads you into the American
gut project and the British gut project
so talk a little bit about like how that
came together and and what that was all
about and kind of what you discovered as
a result of that
well so when back in 2011 there was no
one really doing microbiome research in
the UK and most of it was going on in
the US so
um I got in touch with a colleague who I
met at a meeting Ruth lay in Cornell and
we we did all the microbiome testing in
her lab there and she was linked with
this group that had all worked with this
really the the father of the microbiome
Jeff Gordon and um based in San Luis and
Rob Knight was another one of uh
his Protege and uh he learned that I was
really interested in this and I was
doing the big twin study and uh told me
about his project which he just started
the American gut project which was a
citizen science project uh getting
Americans to sign up basically donate
money you know to pay for their own
microbiome testing and I said I was
really keen on doing this in the UK and
I think we could you know the British
public were up for this as well and so
we got together and um under the banner
of the American gut project and did this
and led to a paper where the UK I ain't
provided about a third of them the
subject so relatively it was more
popular in the UK given the population
density and uh but together we did a
great paper
how many were in the study they're about
um
11 000 I think it was in the end um
which doesn't sound much at the moment
but it will it was the biggest study
done to date clearly showed a link
between
uh nutritional eating habits fiber
and health and showed that these these
clusters that you know
measures of gut health which is then we
used something called diversity
um the more diverse the species the
healthier you were and the less likely
you were to obese or have diabetes and
so this was common to the British and
the American populations American
populaters tend to still be they were
slightly heavier slightly less diverse
microbes compared to the British
but the key bit of that paper was that
it it was
the one that found that 30 plants a week
was The Sweet Spot for maximum diversity
and
that's that study still hasn't sort of
been bettered
um many years later and it and it's
that's been a bit of a mantra for me in
the books that I write for the public
about trying to educate people about
what to eat and I think what was really
important about the study is that it
showed as long as you at 30
types of plant and that's including nuts
and seeds and
to some extent herb mixes and spices it
didn't matter whether you had a little
bit of meat a little bit of fish you
were vegan vegetarian whatever
your your gut health was still optimal
and I think
that still resonates with me that uh
it's not about you know that one thing
that you do or you don't do it's about
the holistic view of that what can you
get on your plate clearly
if you've got a big if three quarters of
it's filled with a giant steak there's
not much room for your plants right so
the top level rule just being diversity
of plant life in your diet on a the most
consistent basis possible is producing
the diversity in that gut microbiome
ecology that is going to be you know the
sort of front lines of keeping you
healthy yeah and it's it's a nice simple
rule that means you don't have to be too
strict about right anything else because
if that's your number one rule
then everything you know follow yes
it's nice to have
you know the rich the colorful
polyphenol rich foods it's nice you know
the fermented foods uh we know are good
as well
avoiding Ultra processed foods uh Etc
but that to me is still number one and I
think that's been a a good
you know
a really good way of communicating it
also to the public about understanding
so they want to feed your gut why feed
your gut microbes you do it by eating
right and if you do that
you know you can't really have Ultra
processed food
it's very hard to get you're crowding it
out yeah you're crowding it out yeah I
mean and it's it's an easy rule to
follow it's flexible it's doable it's
easy to wrap your head around what that
means
um and it's withstood the test of time
because that project was like 2014 right
when you were doing that so I'm curious
about how that was received at the time
like we're all talking about the
microbiome now was that the case back
then how were your colleagues sort of
you know receiving this pivot in your
career and this focus on this new
science at a time where this was just
emerging
well it didn't have any of the public
impact that it has now so
the newspaper they were like you're a
Nutter like you've gone off the
reservation well
I mean there was there was awareness in
2014 people it wasn't like you know
people were talking about the microbiome
there was an interest then
um but a lot of people thought it was a
passing fad that like a lot of these
nuisance I think you know as soon as
something comes up a lot of Grants
follow it money goes there
it's hyped up because you write a grant
to Hype it up that's how you get your
money and then it all comes crashing
down again and a lot of people thought
that the microbiome was you know just a
few years
flashing the pan a few fancy mouse
studies you know there's
um a few anecdotes of fecal transplants
that were successful it would all fall
over and most of my colleagues in the UK
were were not keen on it at all and so
the countries are varied about whether
they support or not and the UK certainly
didn't and that's because a few powerful
people in science just said this isn't
going to work it's rubbish we've got to
stick with genetics it's the only way
and also the nutrition uh
the nutrition uh sort of profession
didn't embrace it at all either they
felt threatened by it and didn't
approach it so pretty much on my own
doing this often with U.S collaborators
or overseas collaborators and getting
maybe commercial money and we used the
citizen science funding actually to get
a lot of our work done
where we asked the public to to actually
pay for their our research and that that
really got it going so that was that was
really where we are we were
um
you know up until uh the time when uh
I realized I wanted to do the next stage
and I was giving a talk about the
microbiome and
that's when I met uh these two guys came
up to me and said we'd like to form a
company
and um
with all the trouble I'd been getting
getting money academically
um
I said aha this could be my my big
chance but
you know I'm warning you guys you know
the science is very expensive
and no there's no quick results you know
the way I want to do it I don't want to
do a marketing LED project
um with you know smiling MDS and a
stethoscope on the front page it's it
you know it's got to be serious science
is going to cost you several million
before we get going so I thought I'd
never see them again but they came back
a few weeks later with the money and so
that's where the company Zoe was born
right and the the kind of operating
principle behind that and the studies
that you wanted to pursue were What
specifically at that time
well we wanted to
really test the idea that you could use
the microbiome and other blood tests to
personalize
food choices and nutrition
that there was sufficient variability
between people
that
um
you could use that to predict everyone's
response so give people a real idea what
they should be eating and
came out of this idea that
um
you know there isn't one single diet
that suits everybody and all these
studies like that of Christopher Gardner
the the diet fit study where
you know they competed high fat versus
um high carb diets
and both did well no winners or losers
but within within the groups massive
differences so and at the same time
an Israeli group had come out with with
a study showing that cgms continuous
glucose monitors
um were able to also predict
responses to food so suddenly the idea
was able to combine the microbiome with
these uh these these new devices on the
market to suddenly have a quantitative
way of really telling people how they
respond to these foods and but the only
way to do that wasn't in theory was to
actually do a really big experiment to
prove it and see if it worked so it was
a big gamble at the time
um but luckily
managed to convince uh these guys that
need to be done
and the study was a thousand people
giving a thousand people mainly twins
because I still believe there was a
genetic component then
um
who were
studied at my hospitals and Thomas is an
and a group were also study it in um
Mass General given identical Foods at
the same time and then all their bloods
studied you know and work up for 24
hours and then for two weeks onwards and
it was that experiment which was the
largest of its kind that really was the
basis for everything else we've done
since then and that was the predict
study right and that you know that is
what that gave us the next Revelations
if you like so having known that the
microbiome was different between people
um
there were two other big aha moments
there that when we first looked to the
data one was
when you give people an identical muffin
there was at least a tenfold difference
between normal people's response in
sugar and Insulin to that muffin at
identical time of day in laboratory
conditions so that was well pretty
amazing uh there was also tenfold
difference in there
triglycerides their blood fat levels six
hours after that meal so everyone clears
fat at a very different rate
and up to that point no one had ever
thought to him look because we only take
fasting levels which aren't very
informative
and that really meant that we had
the basis of a big enough variation to
build algorithms to predict how people
would do based on those sort of Baseline
standard tests right so so it provides
this like sort of starting base to try
to begin to understand the nature of
personalized nutrition and lifestyle
habits and the variations you know
between people and how those
you know certain variables that
distinguish individuals
uh
can be uh you know valuable information
in terms of how people respond to
certain foods or don't and when you
start to scale that up with massive data
sets you can extrapolate from that
valuable information to provide
um you know solid guidelines in terms of
do's and don'ts right so that gets into
the sort of Citizen science aspect of of
the conversation that I want to get into
but there's so many things in in what
you just said that I want to tease out
gradually the first being just the
realization that gut health the
microbiome in so many ways holds this
key to unlock you know so many things
that have befuddled scientists for so
long and there are a few things as
complicated as nutrition and and
certainly it's you know something that
is so hotly debated and you know it
appears that it's so difficult to arrive
at any kind of consensus around and you
talk about this in in your books but
what's
really kind of empowering and
fascinating about the microbiome is its
mutability like when you look at
genetics you come with a you know this
is your DNA this is your this is your
genetic makeup and you can say well you
know my my dad got this or my
grandfather got this I have a genetic
predisposition to this and perhaps
there's some mutability around the
epigenetic piece but there's not that
much that we can do about it but with
the microbiome there is this mutability
right and trying to understand how to
kind of maneuver around that you know
mutability and kind of push it in
certain directions becomes the Vanguard
of this whole new kind of horizon of
Science and Discovery yeah I mean for me
it was a revelation because
you know I was a geneticist I've been
finding genes I've been telling everyone
that it's all a genetic basis just blame
your parents right and how you're eating
crow now and and hope that as you said
you know take this magic potion to tweak
your epigenetics and you might you've
got a chance of doing it but it was a
pretty depressing talk and I was sort of
you know getting getting myself down a
bit about it and so it was so
um empowering really to realize that
yeah you know identical twins have very
different microbes and they respond
differently to the same Foods you know
we had these identical twins one would
have a good fat response the other a bad
fat response and
the only thing we could find different
was their microbes so the fact that you
know other studies before us
um you know the story
um some out of UCSF had shown just by
changing from vegan to meat-eating diets
in four or five days you can switch your
gut microbes you can do this stuff in a
few days so unimaginable to change your
genes in that way so I think suddenly
you know
because I was really energized to say
this is really important and that small
changes to your nutrition can have
massive effects you know via your gut
microbiome if we get it right and so
everyone needs to know much more about
gut health and the microbiome and treat
it you know just as you would look after
it like you would your heart right and
getting it right is hard that's a that's
a big hard problem right it's starting
from yeah it's a different place yeah
it's like this I I feel like you're kind
of cresting this hill where for many
years it's been about trying to
understand the nature
and the complexity and just the general
landscape in which the microbiome
operates and now we're in this kind of
transitory period where it's about
applying that understanding into kind of
tangible you know protocols or or means
of of diagnosis and and recommended
therapies yeah no it's it's
um
uh
it's tough and I think we mustn't
you know again realize that we know more
than we do and so uh we are just at the
tip of this discovery you know the
microbiome sequencing is is just getting
to the point now where we're discovering
all kinds of new
um elements to our gut microbiome like
you know
we've discovered this parasite there's
in one in one you know one in four
British people have this parasite called
blastocystis and it's only in one in 20
Americans and
and if you have it if you went to see
your GP uh he'd probably say look it up
and say okay we've got to get rid of
this guy you know it's been shown to
cause diarrhea and bloody you know
problems and whatever
you know better kill it let's get it out
but it turns out if you've got it you
are
a healthier you've you're skinnier
you've got less visceral fat your blood
lipid levels are lower your blood
pressure is lower and it's a sign of
super good health
and it's
um
you know and so we're discovering that
this this parasite actually probably
eats other microbes that are
uh increasing your fat levels so it's
sort of wow it's a sort of predator of
other microbes that we still don't
understand which ones and having this
effect so and it turns out all our
ancestors had this blastocystis parasite
and if you look at all the data whether
it's modern day you know
hunter-gatherers or most of their world
countries 100 of the populations have
blastocystis and modern living has wiped
it out and you know they even see big
differences between
you know MidWest America and California
there's you know where healthier people
are it's a sign of healthy diets and
Healthy Living it's uh it's fascinating
this is just one element of all these
other you know we know nothing about the
fungi the parasites the viruses the
phages that are doing all this stuff as
well so uh let's you know we can't get
ahead of ourselves we could just stick
to the basics as we as we learn and
understand that you know we've all got
different makeups and um different bugs
inside us that could be doing different
things right the insane complexity of
all of it seems like a a perfect
um
Dynamic for uh introducing the tools of
the emerging tools of artificial of
artificial intelligence because they're
so good at crunching massive data sets
and and dealing with you know complexity
at this kind of scale has there been any
inroads with these these kind of
emergent tools and how they might apply
to this field well we've we think we're
just about got to the level so we've now
got we've been looking at our latest
paper at 50 000 uh still samples from
the US and the UK people have taken the
Zoe tests and with those numbers that's
that's that's where you start to get
this real power and so we're just
starting that Journey now to try and
understand it and link that with the
health outcomes but in a way we are
we're doing this on a small level
with our with our studies at the moment
it's allowed us to work out what we
think are a healthy microbiome looks
like in most people so what's the sort
of key ingredients of a healthy
microbiome which has been quite elusive
um so we you know we've got a list of
good and bad microbes that's getting
bigger and bigger
that we find if you get that ratio right
that's that's right that's associated
with all these good Healthcare Health
outcomes and associated with these
um
healthy foods as well so it's the link
between the foods the microbes and and
the health outcomes right right right
right but you need these big data sets
you know like we did in genetics before
you really start to get uh the clues out
that you know if you're dealing with
just hundreds of people it's just we
have too much variation to be able to
deal with it right and and those big
data sets you know introduces this idea
of of Citizen science and you know I
want to get to personalized nutrition
but I don't think we can really talk
about that until we kind of uh discuss
the you know the impact and the
potential impact of of what this whole
emerging world of Citizen science is and
the the kind of Advent of these
Technologies by Dental Zoe and you know
other
you know other kind of uh things that
are out there that are allowing you to
run you know incredible uh incredibly
detailed experiments at a massive scale
unprecedented in the history of science
because
um you know will and I were chatting the
other day and he was telling me like
listen in testing or in science
historically you can have a small
population of people people that you
kind of control and you can get very
detailed information out of them or you
have population studies that are very
general and basic because you lack that
level of detail and control and now
because of these technology platforms
and you know in particular what Zoe is
doing you can get both you can get the
best of both right which opens up a
whole new world of you know kind of data
analytics and the power of of the
results that you're seeing to you know
create predictive outcomes and and again
like diagnostic tools yeah I think it's
it's a real game changer in science
because you know in a very short period
of time we've built up the largest
microbiome database in the world
without uh doing G you know microbiome
sequencing on two and a half thousand
people a week and doubling that very
soon
because in a way people are paying for
those tests themselves and they're all
signing consent forms to say they agree
to share that data for science so that
you know it's not just lost as it would
be in any normal medical clinic or uh
private facility or whatever so it's all
going back into a large database that we
you know we've published I think Zoe's
published like 40 papers now on this
kind of data so it is a whole new phase
I think of science
so rather than waiting five years to get
a NIH Grant or
um so slow you can do this in real time
and get these results back and I think
my eyes were open to this
um
you know we'd started Zoe but then the
pandemic hit
and
um
obviously everything's all our clinical
studies stopped on the Twins and so
while cycling home in London I had the
idea of
uh asking
repurposing the the sort of Zoe app
which was based for nutrition to
understand covid and get covered
symptoms Etc so
it was a bit of a wild idea but my
colleagues George and Jonathan loved it
the whole company loved it and so in
five days we built this app
which
um went live totally RAW full of bugs
you know and thought it would flop at
least we'd done our bit and we had a
million people download it in 24 hours
so wow one of the biggest sort of how
did you manage that
social media um
everyone shared it so this is a great
idea it was the first day of the
lockdown in the UK
and uh we launched a week later in the
U.S
and within two weeks we had two million
and we eventually got up to four million
people using this app uh at a time when
there was
people wanted to unite to do something
and the government was useless
um you couldn't go and see your doctor
you know you were told to stay at home
um you couldn't get tested so it it just
struck a chord
and we were told no one it was over 60
is going to use an app right that was
the other thing to say well you know
technology is not for oldies you know
they have to you've got to send them a
web page or you know or a questionnaire
prove that wrong you know we had people
in their 90s doing this
um and it it absolutely took off and so
it became
the number one tool in the UK for
knowing out where outbreaks were
happening and what was going on and we
learned also what the new symptoms were
which were not what we were told from
the original Chinese uh variant and so
just in real time we were seeing uh as
people reported on the app rather than
old-fashioned science of questionnaires
and you know
waiting a year to validate the paper and
whatever in real time we got a system
worked out with the team at Zoe So that
we knew that
um loss of smell for example
was being reported by you know a third
of people who had you know had all these
other symptoms of covert or tested
positives right so that's the origin of
of how it was determined that loss of
smell was a thing right it came out of
that originally
the clinicians noted it in Italy
so they were saying it was strange I've
got you know ENT people were saying I
think the scenes something must be
happening here but they couldn't tell
couldn't do a proper study so
um
it was a combination of having that real
data in millions of people and we
presented it and you know suddenly who
and all these other countries around the
world changed their criteria it was it
was the UK was the slowest to change but
interestingly because they they hadn't
done the study themselves but um that
was that was a wake-up call about how
fast
this new way of doing science with new
technology with apps citizen scientists
working together could do so much and we
did lots of other stuff
um that I'm really really proud of the
team for doing
as well as the other symptoms we found
delirium in old people was a sign
children got very different symptoms we
we looked at skin we we asked people to
send pictures of their skin rashes with
covert we've got 30 000 pictures wow
um and she formed an atlas that you know
people could see around the world
um we
've some it was covered tongues so
people were sticking their tongues out
taking pictures you know and suddenly
people felt engaged
for the first time they were doing
something and I think it was really
important we did a study that would have
taken you know five million dollars and
five years to do where we we asked a
million people to fill in a diet
questionnaire
um in the US and the UK and and look to
their severity of covert they got you
know a year later and
with that data we clearly showed that
dark quality was one of the biggest
factors in determining uh how you were
likely to die or to stay in hospital
have really serious covert a link with
the immune system and nutrition so this
is all done at the speed of light we
were writing papers right in a few days
yeah shocking I mean so four million
people how many people are on the app
now
uh we have about still about 300 000
still logging
uh daily and we've
but we've it's so it's three years on
now um it says obviously come down from
the millions that were doing it
but we've repositioned it
into a health study app so we've we got
consent to study more than just covid
and we're now using it to do other
lifestyle factors so we realize it's
potential and so
um we
for example I've just finished a study
on intermittent fasting so we've got 140
000 people to
agree to change their method of eating
to eat in a time-restricted eating
window
of 10 hours
and we repurposed the app and and gave
them so they could fill this in and tell
us how they were doing in terms of their
mood
their sleep their appetite
their way to any other any other factors
we wanted to and
uh got this launch really the fast
and amazingly most people
and they could do the fasting whenever
they wanted so we're also looking
it's a way of looking at not just does
it work but how practical is these you
know because you have these tiny studies
done on 10 people mm-hmm
hand-picked volunteers from Stamford I
mean working you know really extrapolate
from generalized meaningful yeah so it
was really cool to see how many people
managed to do it and I think it was
about 80 or something managed to do it
for at least three weeks
at least you know five or six days a
week of just eating in a 10-hour window
and you know we're still writing up the
paper so I can't give you all the
um the details but it was super
encouraging because the people that did
manage to do that 10 hours you know
reported all kinds of benefits
on some of their GI Health you know many
less bloating uh mood improved and
interestingly appetite didn't go up
because well told well if you and there
were differences between men and women
differences in different ages but the
fact we could do this massive study
um at very little cost
uh in in such rapid time really means
for me this it really is the future of
how we can
particularly do subjects that don't get
the funding you know the the sort of
studies about who's gonna who's gonna
give you big money to do meditation
right uh yoga right right right
um five minutes exercise or
um going to bed earlier or uh
you know cutting back on alcohol or you
know just seeing what are the practical
cold showers you know who knows you know
these things you get
you know that you get the aficionados
who tell you yes you know the dedicated
Guru say if you do this it always works
all anecdote what about the real you
know the person on the street how good
useful is it for them how easy is it to
do
fascinating the people
you know because we're told like
intermittent fasting works better if you
um
you you do your fasting later at night
so you don't eat after right right yeah
like that 10 hour window when is that 10
hour window and what are the age of
these people and what are the foods that
they are eating when they break their
fast there's all kinds of variables and
then beyond that there's adherence
issues and are these people even being
honest with what they're reporting none
of these things are useful if you come
in here it's like diets right completely
pointless if you can't stay on it long
term so finding out that you know only
about a quarter of people uh
in the UK preferred to to do their
fasting late at night I you know have an
early meal and then uh most people it
was easier in their lifestyle to like
delay or skip breakfast
and that's just really useful to know
that saying well actually for most
people even if it's not quite as good
biologically they can keep probably keep
that going for years so it's much better
rather than this purest idea that this
is the only thing right people like
what's what's replicable and sustainable
uh yeah and if you do that then are you
eating it you're you're probably eating
dinner at six or seven as opposed to ten
at night and what's the implications of
that but the real power it seems comes
in when you when you layer on top of
that all kinds of other uh sort of
Biometrics from hurry variability the
the the the glucose monitor that's
showing how you're metabolizing you know
your food resting heart rate you know
metabolic rate all these things with
these you know kind of devices now that
all you know establish a matrix of
variables that you can then compare and
contrast to draw you know a more more
kind of intelligent conclusion from just
I feel better or I slept better but well
actually if I look at this you were your
Deep Sleep Number increased or your REM
went up or it went down yeah that's the
next phase I think is to having shown
this works at a sort of crude level
is to try and get people to input you
know either automatically or
semi-manually some of these these inputs
and then rework some of this data and we
want to also
with people doing the Zoe the paid Zoe
program also start having some of these
interventions as well so that
you know you know every every wave of
different week might do a different
intervention so we can actually see well
can you personalize
some of these lifestyle things well can
you predict who's going to do better
are you is there a certain cold shower
person is there a certain early fasting
person can you predict who they are as
well so I think the more you can combine
these things together with these
interventions as opposed to just
observation
um the more you can do it and everything
we've seen is people are super willing
to take part you know even if they've
been paying money they they like the
idea of being in these large experiments
as long as you give them you feedback
the data so in the past researchers like
myself have been
grabbing all the information you can and
then five years later you get a little
you know a note saying thank you we
published it in nature you know you pray
for God what it was right thanks for
your help now it's very much
you know you've done the study people
want to know how they got on how they're
compared to other people
and it's this is what we have to start
to do much better than we've done in the
past but I think it's
I think it's really exciting I wish we'd
discovered this uh 20 years ago
well these things happening yeah the
technology has to you know be robust
enough right and I you know to your
point we are at the very beginning of
this I mean I think there's you know
there's privacy concerns there's other
kind of issues that need to be kind of
properly navigated
um but it is exciting and I think it
answers
um a critical question uh that that I'm
sure gets posed to you from your critics
around like okay so you're making these
breakthroughs and you're trying to
understand you're understanding better
what's happening with the microbiome Etc
and everything that's going on you know
on your platform but like why does this
matter like how are we translating this
into anything actionable like what is
the reality of personalized uh medicine
versus the promise or the hype and you
know how close are we to kind of uh
um bridging that gap between our
aspiration and you know what we're
actually capable of of providing you
know the interested consumer
yeah there's a plenty of critics of
personalized
nutrition which is what you know grew
into as opposed to Medicine I mean
because that's in a way the personalized
medicine has been discussed before
particularly with regard to genetics and
genetic testing and things like that and
selecting drugs on a basis of those
things we won't remember the blood type
diet
yeah exactly a fantastic example that's
right
um so there's been a lot of rubbish yeah
but the the new era of personalized
Nutrition a we've we've published
you know peer review papers in nature
medicine you know high quality journals
to show
there are these big individual
differences that are real
um we have uh performed a randomized
controlled trial of
sort of unpersonalized approaches you
know the standard U.S advice versus uh
people doing the Zoe program
um who have unblind to the results but
I'm
looking at it I'm very confident they're
uh they're going to be good so the
randomized control trial is the best way
to to tell whether it's better than
you know uniform advice
um and I think the other
the other reason is that
as soon as something's personalized to
you you're much more likely to take
um believe it
I think that's what we've shown in all
of these all these citizen science ideas
that if you can
make it this is your response it's not
just the average response it's not like
everybody you know who goes on this diet
does well we know that you respond to
this you will do it so your adherence to
it is much more like your your level of
belief is so much higher and if that's
backed up by science then
um I think you know it's inevitable it's
going to happen so these critics yes we
need to do these big studies we need to
do the randomized controlled trials
these critics are generally you know
hanging on to the past and old style
nutrition and they will be dropping off
this this is absolutely the future and
um I think you know yes we won't be able
to sort out all the problems
um you know we're a long way from I
don't know working out exactly how much
protein
every individual has because we don't
have ways of measuring
protein response in the body and things
but you know for for glucose uh and for
lipid levels and and assessing how much
those people need I think we're we're
doing a pretty good job now so um and
you know I think the studies will show
that people
um feel better
anecdotally where the people were saying
they felt better and the randomized
control trials actually are saying
saying the same thing and uh
I think the bit we've always been
forgotten about nutrition which we
didn't know is things like energy
um it's never really been asked before
in nutrition trials you know what's your
mood and energy like when you change
from say a high fat or high low or you
know whatever it is you switch around to
something that suits you and you don't
get these spikes in your sugar or you
don't get this you're triglycerides
hanging around your body which means you
get less inflammation
we're seeing that in everything we do is
this this report of I feel more energy
right and I think that's that's that's
really important so it's not just about
weight and uh you know the the sort of
external stuff it's it's finding out
what foods make you feel good and well
you know this from running you know yeah
of course of course people do this by
trial and error yeah that the average
non-sports person in hasserole and other
other tricks to do it may not have
thought about it in the same way as a
performance athlete right
um one of the diagnostic tools that
you're using for this is the continuous
glucose monitor
um and that you know I want to talk more
broadly about metabolic Health in
general and how that relates to the
microbiome but with respect to cgms
um there's there's a lot of squabbling
around that as well there's a certain
kind of subset of the type one diabetic
community that that seems unhappy with
the fact that this is available to to
Consumers more broadly and I you know I
believe that that comes from perhaps an
affordability or access perspective
there's another kind of contingent of
people who don't like it because they
think that uh you know kind of uh an
undue fixation on CGM metrics alone
paints uh you know an incomplete picture
of what you should or should not be
eating Etc
um and there's you know kind of the
whole the whole like biohacker Community
around it that's drawing uh conclusions
that aren't necessarily completely solid
because of an over Reliance on on that
variable over kind of a matrix of of
complementary values so can you talk a
little bit about
um
the benefits and and perhaps the
limitations of the use of a CGM like
I've used it I found it to be super
interesting
um I I drew a lot of you know kind of
um
non-intuitive conclusions about my
lifestyle habits and certain foods that
were contributing to spikes and valleys
Etc but I think without adequate
education it's very easy for a consumer
to perhaps adopt less than Savory
dietary habits because their sole focus
is on like flattening that curve we
agree on that
um so you know for anyone who hasn't
tried it they are an amazing educational
tool about how your body works okay so
it's it's like you'd suddenly do this
amazing science experiment on yourself
and seeing how your body's reacting in
real time which is kind of you know it's
amazing really you ten years ago you
wouldn't have dreamed of something
possible and
and we think that within five years you
know most of the smart watches might
actually have some capability to do this
as well so it's not going away
um like any new technology it's going to
be misused by some people or overused or
over hyped Etc and yeah certainly for
the type 1 diabetics
there was a time when they run out of
Supply so they couldn't get it
absolutely understand why they were
angry people just do it for fun when you
know they're risking right
you know fatal hypos without them so
they're incredibly useful but the
um they are a complaint
against uh Zoe was that they weren't
very reliable we did a study where we
gave 300 users uh one on each arm and
looked at those and they they worked out
really pretty well for the purposes
we're using it
um we've also looked
at
whether you know compared to standard
blood tests they are
do they add anything to just taking a
baseline blood sugar and insulin level
on a hba1c and by looking at over your
two weeks your time in range
and the Very glycemic variability You
can predict who's unwell or not better
than those Baseline tests so there isn't
we've shown there's a clear Advantage
even in normal people to having them as
a predictive tool
there are
lots of ways of misusing them I I agree
that if you don't have a clear program
with it that puts it into some context
you would
you know using it just as a toy uh you
reach some wrong conclusions and
one of the common ones is that the only
way to eat is to have a completely flat
uh right you eat a hundred percent fat
diet like you're gonna have an awesome
curve right you just be flat exactly you
just put ice cream on everything yeah
whatever it is and you know you just
just cream on everything you sort it out
and clearly that's wrong and it and
that's why starting with Zoe we we see
it's just one of the of these three
tests really it's
it's it's one part of the your score is
your glycemic score but we need to know
how you handle fats uh and that's why
the Zoe test has a blood spot and your
six hour triglyceride test see how much
is hanging around and of course your gut
microbes and those
you know we need a more holistic view of
it rather than getting obsessed about
that one
increment of it because you have to if
you are going to control your blood
spikes for sugar you've got to make sure
that you're not giving yourself too much
fats you're tipping that so your your
fat to hang around the blood you're
going to get atherosclerosis and
inflammation and also the foods you're
eating are also good for your gut
microbes so if you have a more holistic
view of it then I think it it it it is
reasonable to use these and I think they
are a great educational tool to show
people that some of their common things
they were eating like their standard
sliced loaf bread which they thought was
super healthy is giving them this
massive Spike which you know what mine
looks like if I had Supermarket bread
and certain fruits for example that they
thought were super healthy and like me
you know bananas you know which I used
to take as my standard every single day
fruit
not particularly good for me I think
these are things are useful because they
start making you think about food in a
different way and I think but
out of context I think they can be
dangerous to some people but if you
think about it you're also getting about
your fats you've got to think about how
good that food is for your gut microbes
and except that you will or yeah you can
still have some sugar spikes every now
and again
uh it's normal that's physiology let's
not get obsessed about it but um seeing
it in real time is is kind of cool and
that's a glimpse I think of the future
you know they'll assume someone will
invent a lipid test in real time and
it'd be on your watch soon so you'll be
able to see
how these right all of these different
readings about what's happening in real
time within your body I think it's
inevitable which is interesting and
fascinating but like a real basic
question here is like why should we care
about this like we see you know let's
say you have a CGM you see the you know
the the your blood glucose go up it goes
down
why is this important what is metabolic
health and why should we you know be
paying attention to this in the first
place these spikes in sugar and or
triglycerides are part of normal
physiology so you know our body is
designed to do that way but
if there's too many of them
and the spikes are too prolonged you
either get a build up of
so the sugar spikes will create rise in
insulin which can can start getting
um insulin resistance and long term you
might end up more likely to get diabetes
pushing you towards pre-diabetes Etc and
that build up in triglycerides
are particularly related to inflammation
and you get inflammation the blood
vessels over time that stress builds up
and again heart disease and other
metabolic problems so
it's the idea is that if you can calm
that down so you're not having as many
of those spikes in a day then your
inflammation levels are lower and we've
shown
that they are related to blood
inflammation markers you will reduce
your risk of many common chronic
diseases most of which are related to
some extent to what we call chronic
inflammation the sort of low level
stress in the body and
other Studies have shown that people who
have are prone to these sugar spikes end
up long term with more diabetes and
heart disease so there are there are
sort of links you can make
epidemiologically we also know that some
of these big spikes we showed there's
something called sugar dip so one in one
in three men one or three women one of
four men after a car be say breakfast or
or lunch three hours later will have a
dip below Baseline
and you say well yeah that's not willing
to worry about but we we followed a
large number of these people and it
turns out they
um report being more tired
uh they don't know what they was out
they were blind to their result they
were more tired
um they were more hungry and they over
ate by uh about 300 calories that day
so these sugar dips which you get from
higher refined foods and carbs are
actually making you overeat as well so
they over time will make you gain much
more weight than someone who's not
having these uh these steps so some
people even more susceptible than others
and what is the relationship between
metabolic health and the microbiome like
how does a robust healthy microbiome in
turn help you maintain a healthy uh you
know a a healthy metabolic you know sort
of uh profile we don't know is the is
the true answer but we do know that uh
all this epidemiology studies show that
people with poor metabolic health so
with type 2 diabetes with obesity with
high blood pressure with autoimmune
disease inflammation all have low
diversity microbes
uh poor ratios of good to bad bugs so
there's a clear Association there and
then you can do voice studies in mice to
show a cause effect relationship of
these
sort of inflammatory microbes that are
maybe producing chemicals that are
making the whole problem worse
so it's a bit of a vicious circle so the
microbiome reacts to meta people with
poor metabolic Health end up getting
unhealthier microbes but we also know
that having unhealthy microbes makes you
more likely to also have poor metabolic
health so it's
it's it's a you know it's both cause and
effect relationships so we don't
understand exactly how they do all this
um there's so many chemicals involved so
many microbes involved that
um we don't yet know the details but we
do know that this is very clear
associations and that you can improve
metabolic health so dramatically in a
lot of animal models by improving the
microbes or
uh things like fecal transplants and
mice and things like this so right so in
other words if you if you are are
getting indicia that that
um you're having some level of insulin
resistance
um the immediate kind of first thing to
do would be to make sure that you're
getting 30 varieties of plants in your
diet like improving the quality of your
microbiome which in turn may have some
positive impact on
buttressing against that insulin
sensitivity
is that is that a leap or is that no I
think but that's a that's general for
most of the chronic diseases that are
relates to inflammation so yes we know
that people who have poor metabolic
Health have pro-inflammatory microbes
they have species that actually Thrive
off you know the stressed cytokines and
and all these other stress hormones and
if you can if you can change those and
get some of the good guys in there
instead and drive down the bad ones you
can reduce some of the the impact of
those diseases so these haven't been
studied in big enough
nutritional trials yet but everything
points to that is that is the direction
we should go in it so far we for most of
these disease they don't seem to be very
specific microbes that are involved it's
more the general Community is is all
changed so it's just the environment has
just shifted and it could be something
subtle just by changing the pH of the
gut just a fraction makes a big
difference between it being in a
beneficial or pro-inflammatory and
itself producing more of the problems
that's fascinating and you know as this
continues to scale up obviously you'll
continue to learn more right yeah you
know
um
Christopher Gardner I know you're
probably going to be talking to him soon
did it really a neat study where gave
intensive amounts of fermented foods to
um to volunteers and looked at their
inflammation and immune levels over the
next few weeks and they showed one one
arm was given just fiber and the other
one was given fermented foods and
both groups improved to some extent but
the one that had the biggest immune
impact and reduced inflammation was the
fermented foods group so we know we can
change in just a few weeks
quite a lot of these these basic
mechanisms that are important to so many
chronic diseases and yet most doctors
never
suggest these as treatments they always
you know reach for the uh the
Prescription Pad it's amazing how fast
that is too yeah how mutable it really
is that was the surprising thing that it
just uh it was it was four weeks of
intensive meal deliveries
um so they knew you know they were
getting this this stuff uh and then they
had four weeks where they were just
trying it on their own but it was um uh
you know the results really were very
striking and that's what it had a really
big impact but no one had done those
studies before which is so shocking as
well right right right because we just
said oh that's just yogurt that's not
real treatment you know that's uh that's
hippie stuff you know we don't we don't
believe in that but these you know
luckily they did all as a huge range of
blood tests and and microbe tests so
yeah in a few weeks you can really
change your your gut health and
influence disease and I think that's
that's the message and this whole mess
about why you know medicine might why
food really is medicine and we should
come back to that you know not start
saying well that you have to be a Nutter
yeah you know
did did Hippocrates actually say that or
is that apocryphal
uh we don't know I I haven't seen his
original text yeah
but uh it's nice to think he would have
said it I I like to believe that as well
um the other uh kind of really exciting
interesting field where we're seeing a
lot of exciting developments is in at
the intersection of the microbiome and
cancer research right so
um explain a little bit about what's
going on with that
um specifically with respect uh to
melanoma and to some extent
um even lymphoma right
yeah but it all comes down
to this new approach to cancer which is
to realize that it's actually an immune
problem rather than a sort of mutation
problem
um because we're all getting micro
cancers all the time and our immune
system if it's healthy is picking them
off before they get too big
and so that's why the immune system
aging and cancer I've got this sort of
close link we've never really
um realize how important it was until
these immunotherapy drugs come come
along these so-called checkpoint
Inhibitors which have been sort of game
changers for many people with some of
these solid tumors uh particularly
melanoma but to less extent kidney and
Lung and
some prostate that you're using these
drugs to boost the immune system
to attack the
um
the cancer cell and get round its
defenses
and
um so you know mortality rates were sort
of you know not 95 percent and they've
these drugs have really changed it so
they're sort of half you know they've
halved
doubled the survival rate in in the in
these particular conditions it doesn't
affect most cancers but these ones and
what we've seen is that the there were
some early studies showing that the
microbiome had might have a role in this
and that the state of the microbiome was
was important uh because it was
interacting because as I mentioned how
important it is for the immune system
uh and you want a really powerful immune
response in order to fight that cancer
for that drug to work
so a few early studies of this
suggesting this might be the case and uh
we got together with a UK charity and
got a Consortium of
um other uh cancer centers in the UK and
the Netherlands and we've got several
hundred melanoma cases end stage these
are people with terminal sort of
metastatic cancer going through that
immunotherapy and saw how they did over
a year and it turned out that the state
of their gut microbiome at the beginning
was one of the biggest predictors of
whether they would survive or not and as
expected it was you know the good to bad
ratio loss of
um diversity and
we also looked at their diets and it was
the lack of fiber and positive aspects
those that followed more Mediterranean
diet had like double the rate of success
of survival and
you know these these figures aren't
trivial it's not a tiny amount
if you know real difference between
double your chances of success of
reaching 12 months wow and yet how many
patients know you know the importance of
this uh yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
how many oncologists discuss uh diet as
in in such a powerful way and
um there's you know there's been some
studies in in for chemotherapy I haven't
been very
clear or very large which is you know
this where you just sort of try and kill
all the cells
um
and there's some hospitals like I think
it's um
Sloan Kettering
um
or OMD Anderson where they they actually
if you're going through chemotherapy
they will take a sample of your gut
microbiome and they'll store it in
freezers you have your chemotherapy then
they give it back to you as a booster
and so and they've got
data that improves survival as well so I
mean that makes perfect sense it's
common I mean you're saying it's
immediately what I thought of like no
matter how robust and great your
microbiome is if you're going into chemo
or radiation it's going to get
obliterated right so to culture it and
be able to you know supplement or kind
of you know a lot you know have have a
way of repairing that as you go along
would seem to be kind of crucial and
obvious and I think we're all going to
be storing our microbiome when we think
we're out our healthiest it's always
hard to know yeah well trust me I'm
going to get into fecal transplants like
we yeah we should all we should have
Banks where we're where we're storing
this stuff at our healthiest right so
you know when we Face some kind of
Crisis we have the ability to kind of
Turbo Charge our our microbiome and in
turn our immune system so that we can
meet whatever we're facing in the best
way and as you said there's some other
examples in lymphoma some called heart
therapy is very complicated uh using T
cells and the microbiome again is
proving crucial in those uh yeah
lymphoma just like a type of leukemia so
I think we're going to see more and more
of this and I I'm I think
the cancer area is one that the public
can really relate to and this might be
finally the barrier that gets it across
to the medical profession how important
uh diet is
and diet and gut health because
Medics are still not being taught
anything about this this whole area and
nutrition is still sidelined as a minor
thing but if we can show how important
it is in cancer then hopefully everyone
will be convinced and the word will get
out but cancer patients are
traditionally told to avoid fermented
foods
right they are yeah they certainly are
in many places and I get lots of
complaints from from patients saying
um because what is the rationale
I think it comes the days when at some
point in chemotherapy you you you are
very vulnerable to infections and so you
have very few white cells to to fight
infection and so they're worried about
introducing bugs
and obviously at that nadir in your
treatment you don't want to be given
large amounts of microbes but for the
vast majority of people most of the time
these fermented foods could actually be
saving their lives so there's a lot of
misinformation out there and that um we
need to you know get
oncologists and and doctors up to speed
on on this this new area and it's moving
very fast but fermented foods are really
good for your immune system and as far
as I know that you know they've they've
never killed anybody who isn't who's got
a few you know decent white some white
cells yeah so so paint the picture of of
what the future in your mind looks like
from a personalized uh medicine
perspective and a diagnostic and
treatment perspective when you're able
to perform you know really uh dialed in
specific citizen science and you know
data crunching to you know create
um to create really powerful tools to
treat better in a more bespoke way
I mean what does that look like and you
do like I'm imagining how far well maybe
like you know 10 years from now and 50
years from now like I've I've had
futurists on here I've heard you know
like I think what's happening 10 years
I'm sorry well like you know there's a
lot of interesting breakthroughs and
developments in scanning and early
detection and all of these things that
are I think are really powerful in terms
of catching things early on like so much
of what we perish from uh is avoidable
if we could have caught it earlier and
you know kind of the technology is
getting to a point where we're going to
be able to detect these things so early
on that we can you know deal with them
in a really fast all manner you know
before they become problematic uh but
that's really true yeah that's yeah
early treatment right and and what
you're talking about is just another
piece in that in that broader puzzle
um in terms of like where medicine and
Health Care are are heading but you know
what is your what does it look like like
from what you're seeing well I'd love to
see more about prevention rather than
sort of early treatment and
reverse you know the major threat to the
Western World which is our poor diet
which you know is
is essentially killing us and uh giving
half the population the US you know make
diabetes and obesity
and it's an insane statistic and so
think about it you know
Ultra processed food is is the number
one killer in this and
the studies are clearly linking Ultra
processed foods and microbiome
dysfunction
and we've just let it happen you know we
just let all these chemicals come into
our food system
uh without a proper testing and the
science is now showing that many of
these emulsifiers that glue stuffed food
together the artificial sweeteners the
sugar alcohols all these things that you
see in Ultra processed foods have a
negative effect on our microbiome so
you know I'd like to see a future where
we're not just
fighting and ever an increasing number
of diseases with with expensive MRI
scans we're actually going to do
something at a population epidemiology
level to say you know these Foods
they're like they come to cigarettes in
the 1970s you know they should have
health warnings on them not
um uh health promotion benefits to say
yeah yeah this is healthy because it's
got some vitamins iron or whatever it is
yeah fortified with vitamin C or D or
should be warning says if it comes if it
comes with uh some health advice it's
bad for you you know that would be a
good
sticker um
so I I'm really into prevention and I
think we're gonna
we're gonna see that the tools for
you know rather than trusting in doctors
that individuals are empowered to do
this themselves I think this is the way
it's going to happen and we've seen
already you know how these devices are
changing people's lives just in the last
few years
the glucose monitor there'll be the
lipid monitor
um we know all the major smart watch
manufacturers are going to moving
towards this they'll have laser devices
that will be able to pick up different
blood measures in in you in real time
these will be fed back through
algorithms in your phone and you know
the vision of companies like Zoe is to
also tell people not only what's
happening to their body in real time but
what they're eating in real time so with
the complexity of the ultra processed
food it's very hard to know what you're
actually eating how bad is it how many
of these chemicals are bad for you are
you the one in three
people that reacts to carrageenan you
know which is an emulsifier that will
glue your microbes together but not
other peoples you know which artificial
sweetener if you have to have one you
know would you have this per level of
personalization can only be so
complicated you need apps and advice to
be able to do it to guide you through it
so I think we'll be using these devices
to find our way
uh through the food jungle point us to
say what
ideally we should be eating keep us
logged about how that you know how well
are we doing in our 30 plants a week
hints of new things to try and telling
us when we should be taking our exercise
um relative to where our last night's
sleep was
um everything should be optimized but
also
not just making us robots but making us
more intelligent more educated about
what we're doing so that we realize you
know this is an evolving science and it
and if everyone is part of a a giant
citizen science project then everyone
benefits and I think that's that's my
vision of the future is that we will
have this sort of benevolent
um
companies who like there'll be a group
of people who can pay for all these
tools but that information will pass to
the people that can't pay for them and
they will get predicted scores that are
free and um we'll we'll move
to a time when this is possible so
realizing that you know as we talk about
cancer yes you can have an MRI scan that
can detect that cancer early but
wouldn't you be better to know how to
boost your immune system so that your
immune cells do it
beat that cancer before it seemed
detected by the MRI scanner and rather
than rely upon the food pyramid that's
the result of a political process to
have a personalized food pyramid that is
specific to you and you alone which is
what you talk about in the new book
yeah I think this this is definitely the
future but it but it's also
understanding what the foods we're
eating and you know and moving away from
this old-fashioned idea of
calories
well let's talk about that like it's a
good segue into the new book but let's
bust a few diet myths right like macros
calorie counting like come at me like I
I know you got a lot to say about this
kind of thing
they exist but
you know
their importance has been massively
hyped and the idea you can describe food
buy calories and buy macronutrients
has been exploited to the nth degree by
the food companies
and that's why they can sell us all
these products with these Health claims
on them when we know they're rotten
they're artificial you know they're just
they're fake food but because they have
the right macronutrients on the label
they get a nice tick and we're we're
poisoning ourselves so I think
you know we haven't really changed in a
hundred years uh
basic concept of how to discuss uh
nutrition uh properly and it we're only
just starting to get into this
discussion of what Ultra processed food
is and the different levels of food
processing which the food industry
doesn't want us to discuss because the
last thing they want is some definition
that they would have to
apply to so they are keeping money in
the water on it so the the fact that
they
you know the companies
um you know discuss this in the book you
know love the idea of calories they love
calorie things on menus and they're
describing food bites as if you can tell
if it's food good or bad by its calorie
count and its fat content
it's complete nonsense there is no real
correlation and there are good and bad
fats and there is good and bad calories
Foods you know we need to be focusing on
the quality of of food and that's
totally clear
um like the example I gave you in the
Zoe study of people given an identical
calorie muffin
and
some people react to that in a very
different way and get a sugar dip and
we'll overeat by 300 calories later in
the day others won't
if you describe food purely in terms of
that
all calories are equal
and you just gave everyone these bad
bad foods you wouldn't know that that
this is what this effect they're having
on mood and energy and everything else
so
smoke screen that we just need to get
rid of and we need to start talking
about quality of foods and what's Whole
Food you know what's a whole plant food
not these foods that are made
in a way to falsify real food you know
they're they're they're
designed to reformulate actual food
using fake ingredients extracts
and I think that's
you know no one denies that calories
exist but
you know we can go into the whole thing
about why calorie diet calorie counting
diets failed the vast majority of people
it will work for a few weeks then your
body just readjusts just as uh and
bounces back
the same way
um exercise for most people does the
same because your body adapts to that
exercise you know we're not just
furnaces we're
finely tuned machines that change so
these are Concepts that have just stayed
because of the the market the force of
the calorie counting diet Market the
force of the food industry to undersell
us worse and worse food with more and
more Health claims and I think the
science is now out there to show how
sort of irrelevant they are and how they
are just a smoke screen yeah it there's
sort of a an arms race also because as
the public becomes increasingly more and
more aware of the the ills of ultra
processed foods at the same time the
giant conglomerate food companies are
getting better and better and better at
dialing in palatability and The
Addictive nature of these foods with the
exact recipe or combination of salt
sugar and fat to kind of light up the
dopamine centers and make it impossible
to just have one so it creates this this
sort of compulsive relationship with
Foods we know are not good for us and
yet we find ourselves powerless to deny
right so education takes us
to a certain place and you know human
Frailty and weakness uh you know
accounts for the rest so you know it's
it's sticky to like I've got no I don't
really have a beef with foods that are
obviously unhealthy but super tasty
right
um but
when something is wrapped up in a in in
all this healthy packaging and is sold
to you as a healthy low calorie low-fat
alternative
that's you know that's criminal
um it's it's it's like dressing up
cigarettes as uh as healthy because they
they're low in like used to be low tar
or low nicotine therefore they're fine
right yeah that's that's sort of the
Tobacco Company version of greenwashing
it makes us just feel a little bit
better about that purchase you know
making that purchase
exactly so you know let's have we're not
going to get rid of them but let's let's
have them with health warnings let's
have them with the tax that reflects the
huge burden on the on the taxpayer that
all these foods are costing us you know
so it's hundreds of billions of dollars
a year
um just because of we're eating these
foods and why should the taxpayer be
basically paying for all this when the
food companies are making all the money
and you know and they're getting massive
subsidies to do it and whereas anyone
producing whole plants and fruits is not
getting those same subsidies right it's
wrong right right I mean I agree with
you completely uh but then it becomes a
question of political will and kind of
penetrating the you know the Battalion
of lobbyists who are you know very
invested in the status quo so well well
while we're all getting diabetes and
becoming obese and dying there will be a
point by the country you just won't be
able to afford it you know the Health
Care system is broken so it's it is and
it's a national SEC it becomes a
national security issue honestly like it
it's it's a really huge problem and yet
it continues to persist and and
metastasize which is disturbing but
perhaps we can you know pivot to a more
optimistic or or helpful uh conversation
around like how to guide people towards
those better choices I mean we all know
more fruit more fruits and vegetables
not seeds you know that's the kind of
thumbnail but for the the the conscious
consumer who's just going to the
supermarket and shopping for their
family and is on some level of budget
what are some of the kind of guiding
principles about what to avoid and and
you know what to invest in
well there's a lot to avoid
um but in writing the book there were
some surprising findings that I found
that things that are relatively cheap
that aren't always aren't always
unhealthy so things in cans
um
many Studies have shown that some canned
tomatoes can have higher nutrient levels
than fresh tomatoes for example
um you get a can of beans
they're just as healthy as
getting you know dried beans and doing
them yourself and they're often
extremely cheap really good source of
protein most frozen vegetables and
berries are also highly nutritious and
really good for you and cost virtually
nothing so
um we tend to think of anything frozen
or in cans or in packaging is all the
same but it's absolutely not true as
long as the sauce it is it doesn't have
you know an artificial sauce in it it's
going to be really good for you so that
that was a surprising findings that many
of these these products you can get out
of season frozen berries for example out
of the freezer really good for you
um nuts and you know there's nothing
wrong with nuts as a snack
um and there's a big difference between
some artificially created
um
snacks like I don't know you know things
like Pringles which have very little
potato in them they're actually made of
all kinds of a composite of other things
versus some Artisan potato chips that
you can get that only have potato and
olive oil or sunflower oil
so there are some surprising ones in
there but uh
unfortunately the vast majority of ready
meals that you buy have large lists of
ingredients in them that you can't
wouldn't find in your home and they're
the ones that will cause you problems
they will make you overeat and they will
be bad for your gut microbes and I think
that's a really important educational
message that needs to get out there is
that it's not about the fat it's not
about the calories it's the fact they
have this really harmful effect on your
immune system and
you're gonna eat more and more of them
so they might be cheaper but you're
gonna they're made for a purpose so that
you'll be overeating your family and you
will put on weight and have all these
other diseases so I think it's this
education about what's wrong with
certain foods that are you know Ultra
refined
have the fiber vadal nutrients get into
your bloodstream quickly don't fill you
up and they're just plain wrong we
weren't designed
by Evolution to eat them right that so
to my mind it's it's an educational
um way of thinking but realizing there
are some
you know things that look quite similar
that actually are still very good for
people but they're not eating yeah
um your dietary perspective and and
recommendations although very plant
focused and kind of plant-centric are
not ideologically sort of driven and and
they're not super strict in that regard
they're more like this is what looks
like the science supports and this is
what I'm you know advising you to do and
not do and an added wrinkle on top of
that that I found really interesting in
the book is addressing
not only
um how the food is prepared like have
you cooked it is it better to eat raw or
this is stuff I've thought about often
like should I eat this vegetable raw or
is it better cooked is it better to like
what happens if you overcook it am I
destroying all the nutrients in it and
then also how is the food packaged what
is the impact of you know food that's
wrapped in plastic and particularly if
you end up like heating that food up
while it's in the plastic and you kind
of address all of these which I think
are you know kind of common questions we
all think about but maybe don't pay
enough attention about so can you kind
of unravel some of that
uh well it's a lot to unravel yeah I
mean there's it is I mean you can read
the book but like maybe some sort of
general principles around that yeah well
I think
a little bit comes down to understanding
a bit more about the structure of food
and um
cooking changes the structure of food so
yeah there was a common misconception
that raw food is better for you and the
raw food movement is led a lot of this
and but all the science suggests that
actually lightly cooking food is the
optimal and so lightly steaming of food
breaks down the structures allows the
nudes to come out without destroying
some of these vitamins and nutrients and
these polyphenols we talk about these
defense chemicals that are in all plants
that are really rocket fuel for our gut
microbes that are really what we should
all be trying to get more of that
definitely aren't in Ultra processed
foods so understanding the structure of
food and how you're cooking is really
important understanding that you know
freezing stuff even microwaving is fine
before I researched the book I would
sell and I got rid of my microwave I
thought this is terrible you know so
um but it turns out that actually
it doesn't destroy nutrients in any way
it's actually good and it's much better
for the planet
so in terms of the energy used you know
if you say a baked potato in a microwave
it's much more efficient
for climate change to use from an energy
expenditure
taste the idea of like having a
microwave but go ahead but well I was
like you you know but in a way having
researched the book I've said well if I
care about the planet I should
use both of these tools you know and um
and not be so obsessed with uh uh my
prior beliefs so structured food's
important how you cook it's important
what you cook it with so just combining
Foods together will change their
um
their nutrient value as well so a lot of
these Mediterranean dishes would use
olive oil and garlic and onions you know
collectively they actually produce many
more healthy chemicals together than
they do when you have them alone
chopping up your garlic
uh 10 minutes before you use it actually
trebles the amount of
um these uh really beneficial nutrients
in in the garlic that otherwise would
get broken down so there's all these
kind of funny weird stuff about
structure of food is useful for people
to know in everyday life about how to
cook things
um
yeah obviously cooking stuff close to
Plastics and and you've alluded to some
of this you know the problem of
microplastics
is something we should be aware of we
don't really know enough about it except
there's lots far too much plastic around
and so limiting the plastic that's close
to our food
um is also important
um and I I think the other thing I
I
realized is that no one had really
written a book before that looks at all
the different food groups and first
takes health
then takes the ethics
so you know
where animals you know engineer what's
what's the what's the ethical basis of
that or what a lot of there's a lot of
new stuff about child slave labor for
example chocolate and that and coffee
and various other tropical things that
we need to be aware of and also finally
the big other area is the environment
sure and it was a bit of an eye-opener
because it's quite hard often to balance
these three things when you're making
you're going into a store and you want
to buy something nice and you're trying
to work out all of you know to get all
three
perfectly aligned at the same time is
kind of tough and so
particularly when it comes to something
like artificial milks
so I found that really interesting
because I'd experimented
with cutting out
dairy milk and the main reason for me to
cut out Dairy is because of its harmful
effect on the planet when you calculate
how many cows and methane and land land
use Etc so it makes obvious sense to cut
that out so I switched to oat milk
which you know I didn't mind the taste
of it seemed quite good but then I put a
CGM on me while I was drinking oat milk
and I saw it shoot up so suddenly I've
swapped what was this reasonably healthy
um fat mild sugar mixture for a a much
higher sugar much more refined product
meant that if I was having regular
oat milk it would for me it'd be bad
other people might be fine but it would
that would be better for the planet if
we all switched to open them but it
would probably cause more
um have some disease consequences as
well so there are lots of examples of
how
tough it is to balance some of these
things and you know are you going to get
them from Mexico every every week are
you gonna how do you freeze them enough
and and where do you get the nuts from
so it starts to ask a lot of questions
not we don't have all the answers but I
think
it it made me think and I want people to
read the book to to think about food in
a very different way
because the food choices we make every
day are the most important choices we
make for our health and probably also
for the planet yeah 100 I mean every
every purchase of food that you make is
a vote for the world you know that that
you know will be right so it would be
great if there was some kind of metric
or carbon score or some numerical value
that we could attribute to each food you
know sort of product food product that
we buy that would kind of tally like
what is the carbon footprint of this you
know what went into the the
manufacturing and distribution of this
you know what was the the
um amount of like water and acreage and
you know all of that and you know were
animals killed in this or like you know
so it's it's impossible to put all that
on the consumer and expect them to like
really be able to make an informed
decision especially when the large
larger food companies are doing their
best to obscure any kind of transparency
around that but there are academics who
have produced scores and we're working
with them at Zoe and we do have a sort
of beta score for all the common foods
it gives you an environmental index and
obviously the Zoe program is designed so
that you you know you get your a general
Zoe score and I've got my scores in the
book for various things which is a
combination of the three but so we're
we're thinking uh sometime in the near
future of adding in that fourth score
which would be the environmental impact
score so that people who wanted to
prioritize environment above health
or habit as a major factor could
actually have that but it is so
complicated it would be that does need
algorithms and an app you can't retain
all of this stuff in your head knowing
if that avocado comes from Mexico or it
came from California you know what's the
difference or you know and also labeling
is not reliable it could you know all
the all the the obscurant language
around labeling you think you're buying
something that was grown in a certain
way and you know it most likely wasn't
and that opens up a conversation around
you know a different
um
you know a different component of of the
microbiome which is the sensitivity of
our of our you know larger microbiome
not just to the foods that we're eating
but uh environmental toxins the air that
we breathe the personal care products
that we use Skin Cream shampoos Etc and
not for nothing the pesticides that find
their way onto the foods that that we're
eating that we're not even aware we're
consuming whether we're washing them or
not
um and there's a spectrum of of harm
associated with that but you know how do
you think about
that and have there been studies done to
give us a real grounded scientific sense
of the harm or lack of harm
like what is the level of concern that
we should have around that
well in researching the book I mean
obviously looked at things like
glyphosate and herbicides in particular
because I was wanting to look at
exposures that nearly everyone has had
and the problem with this kind of study
it's pretty hard to find people who
haven't been exposed because whether you
live in a rural area and there's lots of
spraying around you or you eat a lot of
vegetables
or you eat breakfast cereal we are going
to be glyphosate coursing through our
veins all of us have glyphosate and yes
the Studies have shown that if you have
organic food
it has a fifth of the glyphosate levels
of non-organic food but you're still
getting some
so everyone's exposed to some love
because it's just blowing around in the
Wind from the neighboring farm and finds
its way into the soil of the Arc of the
organic farm and obviously as I start to
eat more plants I get a bit more nervous
about this because you don't get
glyphosate on beef for example or you
know um or meat you get a whole bunch of
other stuff but but you know so it's but
you obviously compensated by you're
eating lots of plants or vegetables
would think you're doing the right thing
but if it's not organic you are actually
ingesting more glyphosate
and uh I I said whereas there are also
certain types of plant where you get
many more so if you like oats and I know
Americans love their oatmeal uh in the
morning think it's a healthy food
um it has really high levels of
glyphosate when people have tested
breakfast cereals because
oats and Rye to dry them out they they
spray it out this way of harvesting it
quicker so use for different purposes so
I have a real problem with something
that we're ingesting every single day of
Our Lives what effect that has on our
bodies now
the science isn't the epidemiology isn't
conclusive there's a suggested increases
lymphomas
and there are some there have been some
court cases on that
um
they've done some mouse studies that
show that
it does affect the gut microbiome
because these these chemicals were
designed so they didn't affect human
genes so they don't not supposed to
interact with human genes but they're
supposed to kill plant genes and they
and as collateral damage they take out
uh quite a few of our microbial genes as
well so we are seeing disruption in the
gut microbiome due to glyphosates and
they
animal models have shown that they do
produce abnormal chemicals now that's
really all we know at the moment
um so it's nothing definitive but is
sufficient to worry about and there have
been epidemiology studies such as one in
France where they compared a group of
people having organic foods regularly
versus non-organic foods and found big
differences in cancer and
um and mortality levels over over the
next 10 years so there's enough for me
to worry about
um I'm also worried about microplastics
um I think we don't understand that and
they we do know that they do get into
our gut and can cause disruption in our
in our gut microbes as well and
um they're also enough
if you eat a lot of fish you know
because you think fish are healthy and
they go into that in the book you're
going to be eating and if you go to a
nice non-sentient fish like mussels uh
and say okay I can eat those
they're great they're really healthy
nutritious but they've got a lot of
microplastic in them because they they
suck it out of the sea so we're sort of
screwing up our planet slowly so all
these good things
um we're having a problem with but
so you know I I think there is pretty
clear evidence that um
these pesticides Etc and uh
are bad for newborn babies and and
pregnant women
and increase they've done some small
scale studies
evidence for the whole population isn't
yet
indefinite but certainly if you can
afford it then definitely go go organic
is my advice it's it and unfortunately
in most countries it's still more
expensive and that's a problem but yeah
I do worry about that but having said
that it's still better to eat vegetables
and uh
not worry about the pesticides to not
eat the vegetables and the fruits yeah
and you can go to the environmental
working groups list of The Dirty Dozen
there's a spectrum of of harm with
respect to that if you're budget
conscious about what what's the most
important food group to be organic
versus conventional
but it yeah but for your breakfast
cereal in the in the US is one of the
biggest uh sources well you should just
get rid of that of that don't just cross
it off the list
have a health warning like a cigarette
packet and then say yeah if you have
this at your own risk you can't sue us
if you get cancer
um what is your thoughts a big piece of
let me preface this by saying
um I think I think you know the
scientific consensus is pretty clear
that if you want that you want a healthy
microbiome that having a robust and
healthy microbiome is so crucial to so
many facets of health and we're only uh
and and that and that the level of that
um relationship and importance is only
growing as more science is coming out
and a key component to maintaining the
robustness of that ecology is a
diversity of plants in your diet you
talked about 30 plants a week
um eating a diet that's high in fiber
uh that is high in prebiotics and
fermented foods which are probiotics Etc
um and with that
what is your response to this growing uh
enthusiasm around what's being called
the carnivore diet which is a diet that
is if not exclusively meat is almost
entirely meat based
there's a lot of people particularly on
the internet who are espousing the
benefits of that saying how much better
they feel how it helped them resolve
whatever kind of chronic ailment they
had and this seems to be more than a fad
at the moment like there's a lot of
people who are
um
very enthusiastic enthusiastically uh
you know sharing their anecdotal
experience with this
well the good the good side of it is
generally these people are not having
Ultra processed foods agreed so they are
doing some good in that
where uh and I I also get people saying
I've been on a carnivore diet for two
years I feel great you know what are you
talking about you need all these plants
um
we do know that people who don't eat
plants a variety of plants have less
diverse gut microbes their microbial
health is is generally poor which means
they will have a poorer immune system
and
so my my worry about the carnivore diet
is that it is
it may work short term they might feel
better and
not everybody I know some people who
really can't tolerate those those levels
of uh meat or fats
and we know this is there's individual
variations there are some people who can
tolerate it and for a short while we'll
feel better might lose weight might feel
they're getting you know they're feeling
stronger Etc and that I think that's
genuine but long term they're going to
be causing harm to their system their
immune system because they're not
nourishing those gut microbes they're
you know the average American has
you know only half
the microbial species of say that has a
hunter ancestors
through antibiotics through poor Foods
or Ultra processed foods etc etc so
they're going to be denuding that even
more and so that means their Armory of
chemicals that they can use to fight
infections to help
negotiate their energy balance their
metabolism Etc is going to be used up so
whenever they have a problem they're
gonna they're gonna be in trouble they
just won't have the tools to be able to
deal with it and have an immune system
that I think is going to be wanting for
most people I'm not saying there are
some rare individuals who might be able
to get by for longer than others without
this problem for in general it's a
problem and I think the other
misconception is this is what our
ancestors ate I mean I spent a week with
the hadza tribe
um about five or six years ago and
saw it firsthand what these
hunter-gatherers in Tanzania what they
actually eat and
you know I exactly as they did and
you know I was filled up at about 10
o'clock with Baobab porridge which is um
this this just falls off the trees and
you mash it up with a bit of water and
that's your huge high fiber Mass so you
can't stop farting after that you know
you're just so full of fiber using
berries then at lunch time you'd have
the women would dig up tubers which are
like you know
uh
ancient yams I guess a form of sweet
potato and that would be
um lunch and then
the guys would go out and do a bit of
hunting and on top of that they would
bring back some meat if they if they
found any but the large periods of the
Year they'll be having no meat uh and
their most of their calories would come
from the carbohydrates and if there's
honey around they they didn't want meat
they just uh they just went for the
honey they just uh they stopped hunting
completely they uh you know just
satiated themselves on the honey so it's
people have a very different perception
of what our ancestors were actually
doing and the majority of what their
food it was was plant-based uh and
carbohydrate-based it wasn't a high
protein high fat diet and they have the
healthiest gut microbes they don't get
chronic diseases they never get cancer
all these things that we've now
developed as part of the West so so the
hutter is for people that don't know uh
an African traditional hunter-gatherer
tribe that has been able for the most
part to maintain their lifestyle and
their Traditions amidst a rapidly and
kind of encroaching developing world and
they have the most robust microbiomes
because they have a very robust
environment and extremely diverse uh
amount of plant life on which they you
know pers they they sort of persist and
exist right
um but it's it's it feels like there's a
there's a deadline on that uh what I
don't know when were you there like it
like it's the world is encroaching on
them right and some of their Traditions
are beginning to erode and their dietary
habits are are starting to kind of shift
as a result of that yeah which is awful
the area they're in is getting squashed
by people cutting down trees around them
and posture lists moving in and of
course
you know they've got all these
researchers around them now right
everybody wants to study I have a guy
coming in tomorrow who went down and
lived with them also yes uh for
different reasons but yeah uh so yeah I
mean
you know hopefully they will survive a
bit longer
but it they're sort of running out of
room and uh they are the last true
hunter-gatherer tribe really in
um in Africa and uh but I think it's
really important we do learn the lessons
from them and we've learned so much
about sleep and exercise and calorie
burning and all these amazing things
that have gone counter-intuitive to what
we we believed we thought you know
um the fact they don't burn
many more calories than we do and you
know
um
and they're not you know they're not
running all the time either you know and
they're happier and they're more
connected to their community and their
neighbors and their family members and I
think for the most part anybody I know
that's had any contact with them said
you know basically they're they're happy
they're doing it a lot better than we
are exactly and there's you don't see a
Beastie you don't see diabetes you know
and they die when they fall out of trees
or they get hit by animals so you know
it's not they don't live to a ripe old
age but um they don't really have a
concept of age
and it was just interesting and you know
it was fascinating to see them you know
I asked them when do you have breakfast
and they didn't have a word for
breakfast
so this is again you know an invention
of perhaps Kellogg's that we all have to
have breakfast and uh otherwise you know
we're
we're not
um eating healthily and so
you know it is this last chance to see
how uh we did evolve and I think they've
been there for you know at least fifteen
thousand years or in that similar sort
of environment which is you know where
are we supposed to evolve from you know
around the Equator so um yeah it's it's
a Pity but um yeah we've learned a lot
from them
and I I certainly did my microbes
actually um
uh you tested before and after right
yeah so uh and I was eating everything I
had so the bear bab the yam but you know
we one day we it was porcupine was on
the menu so you know um which is not
something you get regularly and various
other animals that I had no idea what
they were but they they all got thrown
on the barbecue but
you were surrounded by animals and dirt
and um they're the microbes as well so I
think
part of this is also their environment
that we've lost as the soil the cities
everything sterile you know we're not we
need to go back to hugging trees and um
uh Getting Back To Nature and that's why
gardeners have better microbes than
non-gardeners you know I think we also
realize it it's external as well as what
we eat as well it's important but um
yeah about microbes
um improve by about
30 percent in diversity while I was
there but
when I got back on airplane food on the
way back but you know by the time I got
back to London it had gone straight back
to to where did you keep that culture
though and store it for future
uh proliferation I yeah I wouldn't have
got food security yeah
uh yeah I mean that that conjures up the
next thing which is is is the future of
fecal transplants like it does seem like
there's something interesting there like
if you can one the more
we learn about
the microbiome and the more we figure
out how to kind of
cultivate a very bespoke ecology for a
particular individual
the idea of these fecal transplants
seems to be a really good idea
I think it's a great idea and but I
would say that
The Hope and hype we had 10 years ago
hasn't played out as much as I would
have hoped
um it is the number one treatment for a
couple of conditions mainly really bad
infections
and something called recurrency def
Clostridium difficile you get recurrent
diarrhea
30 times a day usually caused by
antibiotics overuse
that is
90 of the time cured by you know a
single uh transfusion of a healthy donor
uh
stool sample
but
they're not many other conditions where
it's shown to be nearly as effective and
the early hope that it would be a a cure
for obesity has been shown to be false
so you can't take someone skinny skinny
feces and put them into a an obese
person and make them skinny doesn't work
um but isn't there there are some in
disha around Cravings though isn't there
with this or no
there are autoimmune diseases well it it
does work in a proportion of people with
alternative colitis which is an
autoimmune disease so that's the other
hope because there's at least one
disease where
um I think it's about one in four or one
in five people have remission so they
it's like there's you know there's no
sign of the disease after it which is
pretty much as good as the drugs the
medicines the immunotherapies that
they're given which is is pretty good
but it doesn't work for other related
conditions
um other autoimmune conditions doesn't
seem to work nearly as well so we don't
really understand what it is and it it
could be that you know the microbiome
of the host the person who's you know
the sick person has to be so bad there's
literally nothing there in order for the
new microbes to colonize and take over
and if it's too stable it's really hard
to gain a hold plus the fact we haven't
matched up the donor and the recipient
very well
and we don't know what the magic factors
are so I think there's still time to do
it but I think uh it's not looking as
hopeful as it was
um perhaps 10 years ago to be you know
the Cure All For Everything But the
exceptions to this are in cancer
where they've done a couple of cases of
people who survived metastatic melanoma
responded very well to immunotherapy and
they took their their stool sample and
they gave that to people who'd failed
immunotherapy and were about to die and
a reasonable portion were rescued wow so
there could be very specific cases
for people who have very bad microbes
where
they just need that extra shot to to
improve them so I think we're still
finding our way and
um
trying to get around this idea that
because we're so different
it's very hard to come up with a sort of
one-size-fits-all solution and they
don't quite know whether to get 10
donors and put them all in a you know a
magic mix and uh and serve up that soup
or they should be specifically looking
for certain microbes or you should be
artificially producing these
um fecal transplants and there are
trials going many trials going on
artificially to look at it but so I
think cancer is the one area of the most
open excitement
and going back to the idea I think in
the not too distant future everyone's
going to be storing their stool sample
maybe to use when they have cancer
treatment give themselves the best
chance and you know storing up the the
people who've successfully fought off
cancer against the odds and worked out
what it is about those those uh microbes
that are so good at helping that person
yeah yeah
yeah it it's
um a nuanced game as we say but I think
we're misled because a lot of people
thought it was Secure for obesity right
that a lot of people
um were doing this on the internet
and had some very bad results
um another uh source of confusion
uh surrounds
uh the importance or lack thereof of of
fermented foods we talked about the 30
plants a week thing I think there's a
lot of people who think as long as I'm
getting some fermented foods in my diet
on some kind of regular basis I don't
have to worry as much about the 30
plants a week or the diversity of of the
foods that I'm eating how important is
the fermented food piece and then on top
of that
how do we know that the kind of cultures
the fermented cultures that are in these
foods are actually efficacious we were
talking about kombucha before the
podcast or in these yogurts or these
kefirs it'll say you know it has this
and that in it but you know what is the
pasteurization process like do these
cultures you know persist through the
manufacturing and distribution process
of these foods such that they have any
kind of viability once you know they're
consumed
so lots of questions there the um I
think the first first one is I think
to build a healthy gut microbiome you've
got to get the diversity of plants in
there
as your numbers number one
if you don't eat plants any amount of
fermented food is going to really help
you because
the
probiotic microbes in the fermented food
don't actually stay in your gut very
long they pass through and they as they
passing through they stimulate
the other microbes to produce helpful
chemicals we don't exactly understand
that because
but we know that the microbes for
example in kefir or yogurt are these
lactobacilli they're designed to live in
yog milk and yogurt not in your
intestine long term
so they pass through and they have to
have a sort of collateral effect on that
environment they just
the reason we don't still understand
they they make them produce better
chemicals we discussed this Pharmacy
idea they're sort of boosting the
pharmacy to produce those chemicals for
you is the is the current idea of what
what they do and obviously the the
greater the diversity of the microbes
that are doing that the better your
chance of it working that's why
kefir has more microbes than yogurt uh
perhaps 10 times more different species
it's a more complex
fermented food
and cheese you know often has only two
or three
microbial species unless you get some
exotic French ones which often illegal
in in the US because they're they're too
dangerous
um and then you've got things like
kimchi
where the fermented food is you've got
the microbes which are eating the
cabbage and the garlic and the and the
chilies and there may be maybe 30
different microbes in there including
yeast and fungi and
the difference with those Foods is that
they're also Prebiotic because you're
also eating the plants that are
nourishing the microbes so they will
probably hang around a bit longer than
say just your kefir or your yogurt or
your cheese ones
um so and the kombuchas are similarly
complex often uh between 10 and 30
different microbes species
um
but
um how do you tell that so you want to
study it's a little and often as the
rule there's no point having a big once
a week Feast you want to have a small
little shots
and I think studies suggesting that if
you can get three small portions a day
that's probably pretty ideal of
different types of these fermented foods
and how do you tell
what the best products are it's really
difficult we were discussing kombuchas
and
you know I was in a
a store with will we were we were
looking at some of these range great
range of kombuchas in California but
some of them just at the bottom just say
oh gently pasteurized right so it's dead
so probably if it's a little use
although
there is some evidence there are some
microbes that do work when they're
pasteurized but I don't think these ones
have been proven to work and so checking
whether it's been pasteurized checking
its
um the date how long it's shelf life is
if it's if it's live it's not going to
have a really long shelf life
and so you pick up a kombucha you want
to see where there's any sediment in the
bottom is there something like a mini
blob in there that's that could form
and like and similarly other products if
you're taking kimchi or sauerkraut make
sure it's not in vinegar it's actually
live and it says live microbes on it
hasn't again make sure it hasn't been
pasteurized even gently
and
the ultimate test is probably to try
some of these either get a brand you
really know and can trust and if you
don't know them test them you know you
can you can take the sediment of a
kombucha and if you put that into a bit
of tea and sugar
and leave it for a week you'll know
whether it's real or not similarly yeah
if you take the end of a kefir
um if it's live it should you pour it
into a glass of milk within 24 hours
that should have turned into kefir
so there are ways of of actually doing
your own little practical experiments to
to work this out but it's it's a real
um
uh problem for the consumer at the
moment there isn't right like the
consumers shouldn't have to do that you
know to figure this out like we we
shouldn't have to run our own
experiments to validate whatever's on a
label or isn't and beware of artificial
sweeteners as well in in a lot of these
products because we know they're harmful
for the gut microbes as well so you're
doing some good and some bad you might
you know have a better
put up with a little bit of sugar not
too sweet rather than having artificial
chemicals which will have a negative
effect on the on the gut microbes and
what about a proper probiotic not as a
replacement for a healthy robust diverse
diet but as something as sort of a
cherry on top in the book there there's
a study that you talk about with respect
to
um uh covid and kind of outcomes around
uh you know populations that were on a
probiotic versus not on a probiotic so
where's your thinking around that
because there's also a lot of Confusion
And there's a wide spectrum of products
out there
um and I think a lot of consumers
struggle to kind of make sense of that
world
yeah it would cover the covered stuff
first we did a again a survey about a
million people
and looked at their covert outcomes and
whether we're taking vitamin supplements
or probiotics
and actually none of the vitamin
supplements had a consistent effect
uh on preventing the omega-3 the D what
else did you look at like because there
was a whole lot about like if you're on
a team you're going to be in good shape
vitamin C garlic tablets
um
um multivitamins but the one that looked
like it had the biggest effect was
actually regular use of probiotics this
was an observational study so it's full
of potential biases and flaws but you
know it for someone in gut health and
I'm biased to say well that that look
looked like a good result for me
um right I'll put that one in the book
but um we did a few years ago we did a
meta-analysis for the British medical
journal and looked at all the evidence
for probiotics
um and there's absolutely no evidence
that if you're healthy probiotics
prevent you getting disease
okay so for the healthy person to take
them regularly probiotic capsules or or
however you take them uh no clear
evidence for healthy nor people they are
useful there's some evidence that in
um chill neonates early young children
and El the elderly they can be
beneficial so there's some randomized
trials that show they are some are good
in preventing infections or
other problems they also are have shown
to work in uh
if you have for example some GI
infections
in Balance they do they do work there's
some evidence they work in mild
depression in randomized control trials
so there are a few examples where in
this
this irritable bowel syndrome is another
common there's some evidence they work a
bit in the in these conditions now many
people don't work at all it's it's not
totally consistent and a lot of this is
probably because each
each probiotic is different they're
protected by patents so
um they can't be used by other companies
and
our individual microbes are very
different as well so it's not surprising
there's this big difference so although
we can say that many of these conditions
probiotics work I can't say which one
you should take because
the studies have included lots of
different ones so it's
but I think we're in a stage now where
we're moving to the second second stage
of probiotics there's some exciting ones
that have come out of this new science
because all these ones are very old
we're talking about all the ones you see
out there but
um there are some new microbes like
acamancia
um for example
is a bug that is shown to reduce
blood glucose levels in Trials and
actually works just as well dead as it
does alive and it it's it's a very
common
feature in in the new
in all the new microbiology we're seeing
so I think the next generation are going
to be much better and much more designed
for human health than these old ones
which have just been around on some
company's Shelf with a patent for a long
time
so it I I'm not giving you a very clear
answer but I think it's um I still think
much better off taking your probiotics
as food than as supplements
because yeah because you're getting a
bigger mix yeah of course of course and
I appreciate the the the the the the you
know kind of respect for the complexity
and Nuance of all of this like you know
our human brains want that clear-cut
answer don't do that yeah give me the
top and uh you're like uh not so fast
you know even with each one like
everything in this book like you know
there is that layer of complexity that I
think when you read it you begin to
understand like why it's so hard to even
tackle this subject to begin with like
you how many years did you spend writing
this book like yeah so I realized why no
one else had done it and it's a it's
almost in in this day and age a
courageous act to like dip your toe into
the world of nutrition and and make a
statement you know because you know it
is it is it is so difficult to provide
kind of any actionable you know
guidelines around it because the the
science is you know is in many ways so
in inconclusive and there's so many
variables that come into play like you
know in terms of and and the
personalization you know aspect of it
that is emerging that makes it even
harder to say you should do this and not
do this right but we do have to end this
podcast so maybe we could do that with
if there are any kind of concrete you
know rules or or recommendations for the
person who's you know brand new to the
idea of the microbiome even being a
thing and who's grappling with the idea
of making you know healthier choices for
themselves
um you know beyond the 30 kind of plants
a week what are some other principles uh
that you could share because at the end
of you know the chapters you do kind of
like bullet point like here's some
here's some kind of clear takeaways that
I think would be helpful so top of mind
you know what sits atop the kind of most
important of those
well we've covered some of them so
obviously eating the rainbow is you know
the colors are there for a reason and
they're actually really good so
you know don't eat beige yeah the only
beige yeah go colorful
um that's the that's the title of this
podcast
many bitter things are actually good
um you know one reason coffee is so
healthy for you is it's got full of
polyphenols and you know I recommend
coffee over orange juice anytime as a
health drink should be in the health
section
uh dark chocolates another surprising
one
cook cook with extra virgin olive oil
rather than any other oil don't believe
all this nonsense about
um heat heating points yes
um the
um the way you eat is also important so
um
we you know we've we've talked
um about what to eat but uh time
restricted eating we've discussed
we didn't discuss that actually has a
really big benefit on your gut microbes
so all the studies show that if you
leave a big gap
um overnight so your your gut is rested
just as the hunter-gatherer tribes did
you know they're not nibbling uh snack
bars or protein bars at night they're
you know they're resting just as they're
sleeping giving that full circadian
rhythm real chance to real synchronize
so I think that's that's an important
part so there's reducing the snacking
time less meals giving yourself
you know at least 12 hours overnight
ideally 14 is a good way for your gut to
to repair itself and enhance
um eating more slowly
um we all eat too fast a one in five
American meals are consumed in the car
you know it's difficult to have a
leisurely meal in the car
um
just you know wait
do like the Mediterranean countries you
know just don't have snacks
wait and have a proper meal you know
make it a social good occasion enjoy the
food
um and uh you know learn to try
something new every uh
every week you should be aiming for
something something new is extra so part
of this 30 plants is to discover new
things you haven't eaten and you know
get your taste buds
to try something something new all the
time and introduce that to your family
and make make food something exciting
rather than a chore because we all get
into these ruts in our choices we find
something we like and we think it's
healthy we have the same thing well that
you know our microbes don't like that we
you know they like to be tested all the
time so I think it's all about an
adventure experimenting find out whether
you're someone who does well you know
with this long overnight fast and not
snacking or whether you are someone who
does need to eat there are different
people are you an early morning person a
late morning person try skipping
breakfast try changing your breakfast
for you know from a high carb one to a
high fat one see how you feel trying to
just think about how your body's working
don't accept that everything's the same
for everybody and I think the more we
can all experiment
and understand our bodies the better we
get to understand food and live with it
and and always think about your food now
again in these food choices if you care
about the planet really think about
those those food choices you're making
because as an individual it is the
number one thing we can all do to save
our planet
beautifully put I really appreciate it
final Thing Before I Let You Go
would be around
the kind of science that you would like
to see being performed right now like
what is the study that hasn't been done
yet that you feel is most important to
be conducted and and you know what is
kind of on the nearer Horizon for Zoe
and the research that's going on there
that has you excited
well in general the study will never be
done would be a massive randomized
control trial of ultra processed food
against real food
and pay people to do this uh you know
why can't we do that
because uh who's gonna fund it who's
going to fund it and uh we already know
the answer though irrationally the
ethics board would probably say it's
unethical to randomize one arm to the
American diet and the other arm to a
healthy diet
um but that's that's what we need to you
know shake this up so far the studies
have been limited to a few weeks
and uh you know we that's that's where
I think I I would you know if all the
money in nutrition do do that study that
would um
change our system and show show how bad
it did for us
um
the Zoe studies are
it's evolving all the time and
introducing all kinds of new features
and giving people personalized feedbacks
on whether they're Dippers or not
um you know should they be worried about
giving we're trying to move towards
giving people real-time advice about
um what they should be eating uh we are
just starting retesting so this is a
really exciting time people can see if
they've
reduced their sugar Peaks and their fat
Peaks and then improve their gut
microbiome what does it look like on
retest and how they've got microbes are
tested and the results are looking
really good on that and because no one's
managed to do that yet so far
and and so using the gut microbiome is a
pretty good sort of like your dental
checkup that you go to every six months
or so to say how am I doing when I'm
experimenting it's quite hard to know
um I think we're going to start doing
these citizen science projects Within
within the Zoe product so that we'd love
several thousand people to start you
know go on fermented foods for a month
and see what the difference is others
um got intermittent fasting
um all these lifestyle interventions I
think would be really exciting and we
you know want people to join in this big
community so there's a lot there's so
much stuff going on as well as feeding
back these new insights into the
microbiome
maybe getting some of those microbes
into as new probiotics and prebiotics
because
they've never been discovered before but
they have really big effects in our in
our data now we see these these huge
effects of these microbes only have
names yet
and so um if we can harness them you
know they they could be super powerful
medicines as well so yeah there's
there's sort of too much to uh I'm you
know a kid in a sand pit but it's full
of toys and um it's it's a fantastic
time to be doing science yeah yeah well
I can tell it lights you up and uh it's
a really fascinating uh new kind of
emerging field like if I was a young
medical student this would be where I
would want to you know be focusing on
right now because you're at the very
beginning of something that clearly is
only gonna grow and and and become kind
of more integral to all aspects of of of
of of human health and planetary Health
too so it's really exciting and I think
the work you're doing is really
important it's inspiring and uh it was
great to talk to you today so thank you
appreciate it it's been fun yeah it was
good
um if you want to learn more uh pick up
Tim's book food for Life the new science
of eating well you can check out the Zoe
app
zoe.com and uh any other places you want
to direct viewers and listeners uh
follow me on Instagram
uh if you people still do that and they
still do I think they still do you're
not on tick tock uh I wouldn't admit to
it
there we go no no I'm not on Tick Tock I
can't I haven't got this with the
patience or technology for that yeah
how's Will how's Dr B doing is he doing
a good job should we give him an a a a
review right now while he's sitting
right here
[Laughter]
yeah good man thank you well uh come
back again and uh share with me more
about what's happening I'm not sure it's
changing all the time right oh yes yeah
cheers thanks peace